you don't go to school to learn you go
to school to get a degree and that
degree hopefully helps you get a job
that you're looking for but you don't go
to school to learn there's just so many
more effective ways to learn than to go
to a university I went to University I
don't regret that I went to University
and it was 20 years ago that I went to
University and I thought I wanted to be
an investment banker and at the time
being an investment banker you needed to
have a University degree if you want to
become a doctor or a lawyer or an
accountant you have to go to school you
have to go to school to get the degree
to then allow you to get the
opportunities how are you going to get
real world experience as a doctor
without any kind of degree if you want
to be an entrepreneur it's only becoming
more and more useless I mean it was
pretty useless for me 20 years ago my
fourth year graduating class Small
Business course I was already running my
company at the time and it was honestly
a waste of time everybody who was in the
class was thinking of doing coffee shops
and these little businesses and I I
wanted to build a huge biotech software
company my professor didn't run a
business and it was just trying to
wasted time I ended up most of the time
being on my laptop and working on my
business that was 20 years ago now I I
can't even imagine what it'd be like
right now and how boring it would be and
how useless or relevant it would be and
how much I just want to be skipping
class and making videos me motivation
watch the top 10 with believe Nation hey
it's Nina Carmichael and we made these
videos probably because you're the most
ambitious person
you know you're capable of much more and
you need that push Fest around yourself
with the best so today let's learn from
one of the best my husband ever
Carmichael and our take on his top 10
rules for Success enjoy
I was a good student I never skipped
class it was more that I was probably
afraid of missing out on stuff and
failing tests so even though I have a
lot of entrepreneurial Tendencies I
still I still did you know pretty well
in school and showed up the classes and
did all the assignments but I wasn't
happy about it and it felt especially
the small business class felt useless
you know if I'm taking economics classes
and I'm taking accounting classes
those felt a lot more practical than
that it would it would guide me towards
being an investment banker I had to I
had to have those classes on my on my
resume but the small business one just
felt like a giant waste of time think
about your own education experience most
of
high school college is just memorization
right you're just memorizing stuff it's
the connections to other people which
can be helpful and and then memorizing
you don't actually learn very much like
how much do you actually remember from
your your stats class or math class or
calculus or French or whatever like how
much did you actually most of it is just
memorization I'm not actually completely
anti-education it's just more uh through
your actions map to your Ambitions so if
you want to be an entrepreneur you're
going to get nothing pretty much from a
university of Education if you want to
be a doctor then you have to go off and
do it and it's not so much that you're
learning amazing things because you
could learn you can learn it in much
faster ways if you care about something
you're going to learn a lot more and if
you see it being practical and
applicable to your life you're going to
learn a lot faster I remember being in
stats class
and
uh statistics was super boring to me I
memorized a whole bunch of things in
formulas and never applied it didn't see
how this was relevant and so instantly
forgot it and then I was working on a I
have my own software company now and
tool that we're using and
we're split testing different thumbnails
one versus the other and I wanted to be
statistically significant and I
remembered that term from my stats class
like well how do you calculate that
again now that it actually became
applicable to me now I'm suddenly
interested in it and when you care about
something you're gonna you're gonna be
more interested in it and you're gonna
learn it and it'll stick where most of
the stuff that we learn in school you
just don't find it relevant or helpful
and so it doesn't stick and so again
there's much faster ways to learn
it's caring about it it's being in the
community of other people who are
learning
um but the point of school is not to
learn the point of school is to get the
degree so you can get the job and if
that's what your goals are awesome you
still have to play that game and if it's
not your goals then
then how can you better achieve your
goals right I like get there still
pressure and maybe your family's forcing
you to do it or you still think that any
eyes Society that's the best thing to do
but man is as long as you're making
decisions based off of other people's
opinions you're never gonna win you know
if you're living your parents version of
your life or you're living society's
version of your life you're just never
gonna win that doesn't mean that you
just drop everything and you know just
throw it all away
but are you taking enough action and
enough steps towards building the thing
that you want to build and
maybe that means taking a year off maybe
that means taking a semester off maybe
that means starting your side hustle
like there's one thing just to complain
about a life that you don't like
but the more important thing is there
are you taking action the amount of
people who are complaining about the
thing that they're doing that they don't
enjoy but at the same time we're taking
zero action towards the thing they want
to do the thing that you claim you enjoy
are you spend enough time have you
scheduled it in are you is it in your
calendar that consistently you're taking
some kind of action towards the life
that you want to build or not and for
too many people it's no you're just
complaining about a life that you don't
like but a school system that you don't
like about a job you don't like you know
about a relationship you don't like but
what are you doing to actually fix it
and again doesn't mean you have to burn
the boats and go all in and and you know
pour garbage all over your boss's office
or quit school right away right it
doesn't have to go all in right away but
you do have to take consistent action
towards building a life that you do want
I look at movement makers as an example
and that's my that's my training program
it's my mentorship program where I every
two weeks I get thought leaders together
who are trying to build build their
audience build their Community they have
a movement inside them that they want us
to get into the world and so we talk
about making videos and winning on
social media and getting book deals and
becoming a speaker and how do you get
that thing that's in your heart you know
how do you get that that message here
out to the world and we meet every two
weeks and it's the greatest educational
thing out there for people who want to
become thought leaders right if you
don't want to be a thought leader you're
going to be bored and find it a waste of
time if you want to be a thought leader
it's the best thing in the world and
it's training with me but it's also
connection to community of other people
who are doing it so when you want to
learn something I look at them and
they're doing it and they're taking on
challenges and they're making videos and
all of a sudden now they're starting to
get an audience and starting to get
clients and building a business and
that's the best
you know it's the best
and the fact that they're not just doing
it by themselves but they're doing it
with other people that you're part of a
community when you're around other
people who are also learning learning is
one thing and going from education to
self-education like traditional
education formal education to
self-education becomes a game if you
want to learn right traditional
education the goal is not to learn the
goals to get a job cool that's your goal
awesome if you want to learn you have to
flip the model from traditional
education to self-education stop blaming
a traditional education system it's just
not designed to learn that's not what
you're there for
if you want to learn you have to create
your own self-education program you have
to go learn from the people who've done
the thing that you want to do model
success be around and take consistent
action and get some kind of community
because the learning amplifies when
you're when you're not doing it alone if
you feel like you're always alone
everything is on your shoulders nobody
around you understands nobody else is
trying to do something similar to you
you're isolated you don't feel like you
belong that that's really hard it's not
that it's not possible it's just
insanely difficult and most people will
quit along the way or at the very least
just not take enough consistent action
but when you're around to the people who
are doing the thing who are also
committed who are learning who are
you're teaching each other and you feel
like you're not alone on the journey
it's one of the biggest improvements I
made to movement makers
was at the very very beginning it's 85
minutes every two weeks right so the
very beginning it was me teaching for 85
minutes because I thought you know what
got to get the education out Teach as
much informations in my brain pour it
into your brain let's go
and what I found was some of the best
elements that movement makers is having
them having the members connect to each
other
and creating breakout rooms for people
where they can share their experience
explain what what road they're on
creating a Discord where people can
share their wins get help from each
other so that's not all flowing through
me but then they're connected to each
other and when you can create a family
people who are also learning the same
thing that you're learning and when
you're around those kind of people
everything changes when it's not just
you pushing the ball uphill every single
day all by yourself everything changes
and so moving from traditional education
to self-education to actually if your
goal is to actually learn and then
finding a community a people who are
like-minded who are also chasing down
their goals and their dreams you get
that man the next year will be you'll be
unstoppable you'll be unrecognizable
like the person who you will be in one
year compared to who you are right now
you won't even recognize wow that's who
I used to be
that's how you turbocharge your growth
invest in self-education and get around
a community of like-minded people who
will push you forward rule number two
create your own future the whole point
of being an entrepreneur is to create
your own future that's why we start our
own businesses we want to build a new
world we want to be the change that we
want to see right why do you start a
company why do you become an
entrepreneur because there's a problem
in the world that you don't like that
you want to fix and you want to see a
change that's right that's why we do
what we do the challenge is how do you
consistently believe in it you know
because you have these moments these
days when you love it and you're on top
of the world and you're on fire and
you're motivated and you can do this and
then most days you'll wake up and feel
like who am I I can't do this I'm not
good enough and it's not going to happen
right does it happen to you
this roller coaster ride of ups and
downs of emotion and just belief that
it's possible for you I got asked
yesterday
uh how did you make so many great
contacts with huge people at the
beginning of your career and the answer
is I didn't I didn't I struggled at the
beginning I was nervous and shy and
Afraid and felt not good enough and
never reached out to people it was a
long journey one of the only reasons why
I had any level of successes I just kept
going you know five years in and having
7 000 subscribers I just I just kept
going I just kept making and what I
started entrepreneurship thought
leadership at 22 when I started making
content 22 I'm now 42 by the time this
video comes up so 20 years of making
content you know eventually you you make
some connections and get good at
something but hopefully the process can
be a lot faster for you
and the way through it is I think the
environment's like okay how do you fix
it well environment how do you
consistently believe in yourself is the
environment it's what you're surrounding
yourself with it's the people in your
life it's the videos you're watching
it's the content you're consuming it's
the people you follow on Instagram it's
the environment
that when you are around the people that
make you feel like things are possible
you will you will start to feel like
things are possible it's like whoever is
more confident wins so the if you're
around people who are constantly
negative telling you you can't do it
gave up on their dreams the chances of
you
being able to go chase your dreams
around those people is is really low
it's not impossible but it's really low
and I think the the people who've killed
the most dreams are the people around us
right your parents your friends your
environment your community they've
killed your dreams and ultimately yes
it's your responsibility but hanging
around them and injecting their not not
that they're haters or or bad people
just their limited thinking and their
unhappiness right they're hurt they're
they're struggling themselves they don't
like their own life and they're scared
they feel trapped and so when you're in
that position of fear and trapped and
scared you don't make good decisions and
you also don't give great advice and so
how do we fix it a couple things that uh
I wish I did earlier and so maybe you
can use this as counsel to help you
believe in yourself more consistently so
number one is to limit access or cut out
the people who are feeding you
negativity if you're hanging around
people who
just make you feel worse about yourself
that every time you talk about your
career your dreams or what you want to
build they tell you that it can't be
done that it's not possible then then
limit access or just cut those people
out of your life it's just not worth it
and I say give the option because you
know maybe that's your mom telling you
that maybe that's maybe that's somebody
close to you telling you that and some
people do take the step to cut their
parents at it that may not be how far
you want to go but at least limiting
access so that if you're gonna hang out
with your mom you're just not talking
about your career you're just not
talking about your business it's
hopefully other things that you can
connect on besides uh just what you're
doing for a living or what your goals
are right so cut those people out or
limit access severely
so that you don't feel so negative all
the time I think it's really important
okay so that then creates a void that
Creole okay well now who am I hanging
out with because if you actually didn't
audit of the people in your life you'll
probably find that most of the people
are not the ones that fill you up you're
the ones filling other people up
so we need to start finding people who
do fill us up so step two is to then
join groups and to be around people and
to be around the communities that are at
least like-minded you know as somebody
who's introverted and shy myself it can
be really hard and I think as adults it
can be really hard to uh to make new
friends you know we're not going to
school anymore it's gonna be hard to
break into new communities and so the
easiest way to do that especially if
you're introverted and shy like me is to
join communities so for me I joined uh
salsa dance school that I later bought
that's how I met my wife Nina I would
join entrepreneur clubs I would join
if I wanted to meet new people I would
join anything that I'm interested in
right I'd look for any entrepreneurial
conferences personal development events
or clubs uh any book signings you know
just looking at trying to trying to
start to connect with people who are
more optimistic
and more happy and more positive and
just try to be around them more often
and the goal of going to an event like
that isn't to even necessarily learn
something you know I think it's just to
be able to connect with people and if
you go networking events you go to a
conference or some kind of personal
development session
hopefully you're learning something but
make the goal to just try to meet
somebody you know like there's one
person here who might be the friend that
you need who might be the the business
partner that you need might be the
co-founder that you need there's one
person here that might be everything
that you need and you don't need to know
all thousand people here you just have
to make one meaningful connection that
maybe that turns into a mastermind or
business partner or coffee meetups that
can allow you to sustain the momentum
and the belief that is possible
that being around somebody else where
there's you know one plus one equals 48
because the energy you create together
and the way to do that
audit for yourself is just to think
about when I leave this person do I feel
more or less
alive do I have more less energy do I
have more or less belief in myself and
when you have the people around you who
make you have more energy and more
belief in yourself then you're more
likely to go out and create your own
future and create the world that you
want to create right where most of the
people again we are pouring love and
energy into them and that's amazing and
keep doing that in that service and you
should that's awesome but
um that can't be
the only people in your life you know
because then you just are pointing to
others and nobody's pointing to you and
so we need to start to add in those
people and and they they're out there
they're out there they're for sure out
there I see it all the time in movement
makers that's my that's my membership
group for people who want to be thought
leaders and we meet every two weeks and
I train them and I help them and more
important than even just the education
or knowledge they get from me is the
connection the connection and Community
to each other where they're going live
together there's certain businesses
together they're sitting there making
content you know in their garage or
their basement or their office
uh their home in their kitchen and their
family might be saying what are you
doing making these YouTube videos are
you crazy and now they're around to the
people who are doing the same thing as
them and it just breathes life and hope
and possibility because you've got a
great
heart and a great soul and great
opportunities in front of you and you
want to serve and it can happen it it
can happen it can't happen for you
but again your environment probably
doesn't support it and so it's now
making instead of blaming the
environment and blaming your parents and
everybody else it's making a conscious
choice to change the environment so
again step one is to remove or limit
access of the people who are making you
feel worse about yourself when you talk
about your dreams and your goals and
your Ambitions step two is to supplement
in new people who to do make you feel
better who make you feel more alive and
again whether you're going to an event
or conferences or joining a group like
mover makers but you're part of a
community so it's not just you doing it
all on your own
honest is probably my biggest mistake
when I was starting my journey is just
trying to do everything myself mostly
out of fear and insecurity
um I'm being shy and afraid but
hopefully you can get there a lot faster
and that propels your growth forward and
then number three is be really conscious
of what you're feeding into your mind
with the content you consume and so I
think we have this wonderful opportunity
on a on a daily basis to choose
education or choose entertainment or
choose
creating a new world that we want and
and consuming the knowledge that allows
us to build it or escaping a world that
we don't like anymore like if you see a
problem in the world you have a problem
in your life do you choose to fix it to
work towards it or do you choose to just
kind of ignore and try to shut off the
world right most people will try to shut
off the world just be entertained as
opposed to no we got to fix this we
gotta we gotta do something about this
and so think about the videos you watch
you're watching this video so you're
already on the path but do an audit of
everybody that you follow
do an audit of the channels that you
subscribe to do not have where you're
spending your time and see how much of
it how many of the channels that you
subscribe to on YouTube how many videos
that you watch on YouTube are helping
you build a better future for yourself
are training to be a better person
giving you the skills and the knowledge
to actually go and make that change
versus how many videos are you watching
that are just pure entertainment or just
shutting off your brain and shutting off
the world and pretending like the
problems that you've gotten and you want
to solve don't exist right and I'm not
suggesting that you
never have entertainment
just switch the ratio
if you want to change the world if you
want to create a new future for yourself
your family for the people around you if
you actually want to do that then you
have to start to change what you're
feeding into your mind and again this
channel is a great start you're all the
way through this video so you're already
on the path and
and I mean it's amazing it's worth
celebrating you know high five to
yourself there congratulations and it's
a consistency that matters the most so
what are you doing tomorrow what are you
doing the next day what videos are you
watching the day after that what videos
are you watching next week and next
month
and making that consistent because again
it's easy to get excited as
entrepreneurs it's easy to get excited
and have one day where you feel on top
of the world and amazing and holy cow
can do so much and so many opportunities
and then it's easy again the next they
wake up and feel hopeless and impossible
and who are you to do this and I can't
do that and there's no way that it's
going to happen and why did I think this
is what a stupid decision right we beat
ourselves up and so that consistency in
the environment is the thing that will
make a difference let me tell you this
if you were hanging around people even
just one person who was always working
out who's always fit
they would even without them telling you
you would become more fit you would you
would work out more because you're
around them because the environment they
create
if you respect them would be one where
you would now just want to work out more
and so it's the same thing for your
dreams when you are not around the
people who are who are negative and who
are trapped and who are in a lot of pain
and when you add in people and content
that makes you feel alive and hope and
possibilities and belief great things
start to happen great things start to
happen but it has to be consistent a
one-off video is not enough
every day
put it into your calendar that whether
it's a human being that you're actually
talking to or content that you're
feeding into your mind
that you're going to show more belief in
yourself because your mission matters
because your heart matters because you
have a gift that the world needs and
because you want to create a new future
a better future for yourself your family
for the world rule number three seek
fulfillment the fastest way to
fulfillment is to feel like the work you
do matters
at the end of the day everybody is built
to serve and write a whole book on it
you are built to serve you want to feel
like today matters that you're gonna
wake up and you're going to create
something today that will mean something
to some people to someone maybe it's a
million people maybe it's one person but
you're gonna make something that will
mean something to somebody look at me
I'm sitting here in a parking lot my
wife is shopping at a food store and I'm
sitting here in the car with my my dogs
passing out on my phone making a video
why
because I feel like this matters
I feel like somebody's gonna watch this
video and it'll make a difference for
them and hopefully that's you maybe not
everybody but at least one person will
watch this video and it'll matter and
it'll mean something and
endless
and when I feel that I'm much more
likely to show up I have more
fulfillment I have more energy I have
more kindness I have more love I have
more motivation and when we feel like
what we're gonna do doesn't matter makes
no difference nobody cares if we show up
or not that's the path down to anxiety
and stress and overwhelm and depression
and suicide this is where most people
are most people do not like their lives
most people feel like what they do does
not matter
I think most people wake up and they
drop to a job that they hate and they
feel like today it doesn't matter nobody
cares if I show up or not the work I'm
doing doesn't really have an impact and
that's why a lot of people move towards
entrepreneurship is because we're
looking for more fulfillment because we
want to feel like this thing we're gonna
do is gonna make an impact and at least
somebody's life and if you can run some
of those things together you can have a
couple days even in a row feeling like
this matters
and the energy difference that that will
be inside you the motivation will change
the kindness will change how you show up
or others will change how you talk to
yourself will change all because you
feel like the work you're doing today
matters they did
functional MRIs on people's brains and I
talk about this and build this here they
did functional MRIs in people's brains
to see what parts of the brain light up
when we're helping people when we feel
like we're going to do something that's
even just a small act of kindness
and it lights up the same part of the
brain as having food and having sex
serving others
the same part of the brain is having
food and having sex
we're hardwired to do it if you're not
happy right now is because you feel like
you're not serving that you don't matter
you might be doing stuff that matters
but you feel like it doesn't matter this
is where I get stuck on goals people say
what are your next goals I don't know 5
million subscribers 10 million
subscribers it doesn't it doesn't mean
anything what does that mean
it's more the qualitative stuff that
means the most to me it's the comments
that you guys leave on the videos it's
the people that come up to me at events
and tell me how much the content has had
an impact on their lives like that's the
juice that's why we do what we do
and of course you have to get numbers
and of course you have to drive revenue
and of course you have to like all of
that matters because in making money it
allows you to go and create more and
serve more and help more you know and
build a better life for yourself as well
um money is definitely important it's
got to be in your top five but it can't
be number one
and number one is feeling that you're on
a mission
that you're going to make something
today that will matter so how do we do
it
again I go through the process and build
the serve but basically three steps it's
who I have so who is your single most
important core value and if you get the
guess what is your most important
program what do you stand for as a human
being
means belief so I want to spread belief
everywhere that I go in this video my
intention is to spread belief I want I
want to believe more in myself and I am
hoping that you believe more in yourself
as a result of being around the stuff
that I make I don't always accomplish it
but it's the intention it's the goal
always going in and whatever your most
important core value is that's what you
still need more for yourself it's your
biggest roadblock right now and it's
also the gift that you want to give to
the world to the people around you you
want to help them feel X as well so for
me it's believed what is it for you step
two is your why and your why is your
purpose and your purpose comes from your
pain so whatever you struggle the most
with is the thing you want to have other
people through so I struggled so much as
an entrepreneur a young entrepreneur or
19 year 11 quit on my business partner
didn't think I was adding any value no
contribution not getting any results
working my face off but just getting
zero results no traction and I hated it
I hated it so I quit on my business
partner
I went back the next day but that was
that was
man the worst day of my life and
my why is to help other entrepreneurs
not struggle as much as I did whatever
you struggled with the most is a gift
because you're going to help other
people not struggle as much as you did
and that will make you feel amazing
forever we all love helping right back
to the functional MRIs you love helping
you love assisting you you'll you'll buy
the coffee for the person behind you in
line or you open the door for somebody
or you'll help somebody pack their car
with groceries or help somebody up who
fell on the street or something you'll
do that it'll feel good
um but that's a little momentary Thing
versus if you felt like
there's somebody who you're helping who
was a younger version of you you see you
in that person
and you help them come alive by talking
to you by spending five minutes with you
you see hope light up in their eyes that
wow maybe I don't have to stay stuck
maybe I don't have to struggle and
suffer as much as I am because they met
you
and that's a totally different vibe and
feeling that's that's the thing to get
addicted to get addicted to serving get
addicted to helping get it get addicted
to impacting you know what a difference
it makes and so figuring out your why
becomes really important because well
often
uh just find ways to
try to find any kind of meaning without
ever ever having done the deepest work
and as entrepreneurs we struggled to
often looking back I don't think about
my most painful moment that was in the
past I don't want to touch that I want
to be happy not to Mystic and move
forward well this is how you do it right
the point of looking back at your most
painful moment is not to live there it's
to say there's lots of people who right
now currently are struggling with the
thing that you struggled with before you
can help them and you'll you'll light up
you'll be the greatest thing of all time
to help those people so first is your
who your most important core value
second is your why which is your purpose
and the third is then your how and
that's that's your passion so how do you
want to help people so how so I want to
help
people believe in themselves and
especially entrepreneurs because that's
what that's where I struggled the most
but how do I do it well however you came
out of the hole that you were in is a
teachable thing that you can give to
other people so for me it was model and
success and that's it who has done this
before and I studied them and I applied
that lesson as Bill Gates applied this
lesson to my business and we started
having success now what have I done for
the past 20 years is teach people how
they can model success to the situations
in their business of their life to
accomplish their goals so how did you
get out of the hole that you were in
what was the thing that you did and
where we get trapped a lot is we love
helping people to get the result but we
don't love the process of helping them
so the classic example I use if you're
moving your your your office I love
helping you as an entrepreneur move to a
new office but I don't want to help you
pack boxes and pack up computers right
so I like the end result of helping you
believe in yourself and you've launched
their new
office awesome but I don't like the
process that leads up to it so we're
constantly chasing the result but we
don't enjoy the process we're the number
one rule for Success if you have to
enjoy the process and so we get givers
we get trapped in this Loop of
constantly helping people because we
love helping people we feel good helping
people and we get the result of helping
people but we don't enjoy the process
and so we never get actually great at
the thing or world class because we're
not enjoying the day-to-day work and so
that becomes the next challenge is
however you got out of the hole that you
were in is a teachable thing to others
and we have to enjoy the process of
doing it so it doesn't feel like work
write that whole expression of find what
you love and you'll never work a day in
your life it's true you know I I love
making videos how have I done so many
videos for so long so consistently
because it doesn't feel like work this
isn't this doesn't work I would you know
my wife is in in this store here you
know shopping for for food that feels
more like work than sitting here in the
car and making a video for you guys
right and so there's no right or wrong
you know for for my wife she'd probably
rather be in there than making videos so
for you what's the process that you
actually enjoy that is contributing to
other people so when you can combine all
those things when you can find the thing
you love doing that's a service to
others that is helping people who
currently are who you used to be in
injecting them with the core value that
you've got that you still need even more
for yourself that's when everything
starts to shift so the who I how process
who who sing the most important core
value why your purpose your purpose
comes to your pain and how
is your passion how you actually want to
help people
with their you know through your who and
in your why
figure that out everything gets easier
everything gets more exciting everything
gets happier everything you feel more
grateful more confident More Alive more
momentum you start making more money
it's it's like you're you stop fighting
the world
and you start flowing with it
because you want to serve and you've got
so much kindness and opportunity inside
you that needs to come out that where
you are right now is not is not where
you want to be it's not where if you
fast forward a year two years five years
you want to be in a better
spot
everything wise health-wise emotional
gratitude money in your bank account all
of it and it's and it's possible when
you can connect your who your why and
your how to find a fulfillment that
you're after rule number four understand
the why when you have a why to live for
you can endure almost any how it's one
of my favorite quotes if you think about
it if you've got a strong why most
people are stuck on the how how do I do
this how do I get started how do I write
a book how do I create a video how do I
get my first client how how we're stuck
in the land of how but the problem for
most people is not the how it's just the
why is the strong enough think about the
time where you really had to figure
something out you really had a strong
one like this this must happen we've all
had those moments you figured out the
how that
maybe didn't come right away the how you
might have tried 18 different things
before you found the how but the how is
often when you say you're stuck on the
how it's often just an excuse because
you're you're afraid
the I want to start a YouTube channel
cool how do I do it and and you're stuck
on what gear to use and what microphone
and what topic and you know whatever
whatever the typical questions people
have that probably run through your
brain that ran through my brain when I
first got started too right
really what's underneath that is just
fear
it's just fear it's like fear that
nobody will watch the videos people fear
that people will watch the videos and
you'll be judged it's just fear
if you're stuck on the how it's just
fear talking this is an important
Insight if you can apply this to your
life will make a huge difference if
you're stuck constantly on the how
it's just fear talking and this is your
logical brain guiding you through the
process of staying stuck
I can't tell you how many people I've
helped and giving them the house just
here's how you do it here how here's go
and then there's another question
another question another question and no
action because it's fear
and so how do you get over the fear know
how it's going to take you to the fear
fear is the why
you solve the fear to the why why must
this happen why is it so important why
are you doing this and it's a constant
reminder of why because you can feel
super motivated and excited today but
then wake up tomorrow and kind of lose
sight of the why
I think it's important to apply in three
areas one for yourself two for your
clients or customers the people you're
helping sell to and then three for your
team as you build and scale the company
so let's break down each one
um for yourself
why do you do what you do you know if
you're a solo entrepreneur or you've got
a small team when you're building why do
you do what you do why is it so
important that you wake up and show up
today because you don't have a boss
there's nobody who's going to fire you
if if you don't show up and and do your
work right
it's part of a structure of a corporate
environment and having a boss breathing
down your neck and you know you're going
to have a performance review and you
know that your your next paycheck is
dependent on you doing well right sure
we have our customers as our bosses but
a lot of times entrepreneurs a little
slack off we'll find reasons why not to
do something we'll convince ourselves of
you know why we're not capable and why
this is not a good idea for us to work
on
you know but we're not we're not focused
enough daily consistently on the why of
what we are doing that forces us into
momentum growth and action here it's a
it's a Tuesday morning as I'm filming
this video for you guys right now I've
got a lot of videos to film I filmed you
know thousands of videos over over 12
000 videos I should do account because I
reference it but I don't know how many
like thousands and thousands and
thousands of videos
and it's
easy just to get in the car and film a
video but what's important is the
connection to the wire I'm I'm sitting
in the car or driving to do
some errands and
and it's an exercise to remind myself
why I do this because you guys are
watching because I want to help solve
the world's biggest problem because I
want to make content for 19 year old
everyone who didn't believe in himself
because in learning from people like
Elon Musk it encourages me to think
bigger and push harder and do more and
I'm not just sitting in my car talking
into my cell phone
I'm doing life-changing work you know
and it's that it's that daily reminder
and and then I'll feel that and I'll
press record and here we are making this
video you know right now
and then tomorrow I'll need I'll need
another reminder
at least it works that way for me
it's not that I can just watch one video
or go to one event and then I'm I'm good
for the next year
it's a daily not struggle but a daily
you know just like you have to brush
your teeth every day
need to be a daily habit or you won't
remember it but it's important to
remember because when you feel your why
and you feel like what you're doing is
at least on the path to having an impact
on people you're just going to show up
with a lot more energy and care and
kindness and and drive compared to if
you feel like it doesn't really matter
if I show up today or not so that's the
first one is you building in the habit
of connecting to your why on a daily
basis to give you more energy to push
forward and do the courageous things
that you're afraid to do so you don't
get stuck on the how how's not the
problem you're just afraid
number two is the why for your customers
one of the biggest advantages you have
as an entrepreneur is
your story like why would I buy from you
instead of buying from your big
competitor that that I've known for
years or some big brand name why why buy
from you why buy from you know the
little guy well your story because I
feel like you care because I feel like
you have a strong why if I'm if I'm
buying from you instead of Coca-Cola
why would I buy your drink well because
you have a strong why and I don't know
what Coca-Cola's why is
people aren't connected to the brands
that they buy from for their wine
is how you win and so you're sharing
your story and why you do what you do
becomes really important one of the best
pieces of feedback that I get is on my
website and on the website if you go to
it's Evan carmichael.com if you want to
check it out
I share my story and I share why I do
what I do so it's not just another guy
making some content on YouTube and you
know on various platforms but you can
hopefully connect with the reason why I
do what I do and people read that and
then they they want to dive deeper into
my world and the same thing can happen
with you you don't just sell a product
or service don't just try to make you
yourself look like some
giant Corporation and be professional
like yes you want to be professional but
your story is the thing that carries a
day the most your story sharing it why
you do what you do really really really
really matters because if customers can
connect to your story they're much more
likely to know you like you trust you
want to buy from you want to do business
with you because they feel something in
your story that hits them on an
emotional level that will then use to
justify why we're doing it right again
it's it's our emotions and our heart
leading the way and it's our brain
convincing ourselves why we have to do
it customers if they like your story
and it made them feel something
emotional will find a way to justify
working with you to convince their brain
that it's a smart idea
but it's really an emotional decision so
the first why is for ourselves second
wise for our customers and the third why
as you scale and grow so the team so
we've got 37 people on the team and one
of the hardest things
um
that I've that I've noticed as we as we
grow and scale is making people's
individual work
feel like it's contributing I'm a little
spoiled in that
I get to see all the great stuff I get
to meet you at events and conferences
and I get to hang out with you on
movement makers and I get to see the
comments and I get to your people want
to take selfies and I I get to see a lot
of the good stuff but this is a team
effort you know if I wasn't if I did not
have my team this would not be happening
I'm maybe not making this video for you
right now because I have a million other
things that I have to do and run a solo
business
one of the things that I found really
helpful in my business is
every Sunday I connect with somebody
else on the team so there's some people
I meet once a once a week that are you
know Mission critical but there's other
people now as we scale and go to the
team but there's not enough time to meet
everybody one-on-one once a week and so
what I do is I I reserve Sundays
for connecting and trying to really
deeply connect with somebody on the team
this weekend I I connected with a new
member on a team who's helping do a lot
of the research for these videos and
finding the clips and putting them
together and bringing them to me to be
able to record and
it's one thing just to have a job and
the the the bar for being a boss is so
low you know to to be a good boss really
just have to not treat people like crap
honestly like most people's have bad
boss experiences so just care about
people and you're already creating the
best experience probably in their work
history but I don't think that's good
enough like I don't think that is I
don't think it's a good enough
experience I think people should feel
like they're showing up to work and
they're doing something that matters and
so it becomes your job to connect the
work that they're doing to something
that matters so back to
you know my week my meeting on the
weekend
uh this person who's been doing a lot of
great research for us it's it's easy
just to look at what she's been doing
and congratulate her on finding Great
Clips and
um just telling her what a good job
she's done and that's worthwhile for
sure
but what's the why
does the why to just not get fired is
the why to get a raise is the why like
what's the why driving meaning behind
her work and want to make sure that
people on the team feel meaning behind
the work and so my job as a leader is to
connect
the work that she's doing to the end
result so that if we see people leaving
great comments on the video we see
people making life-changing decisions we
see people growing their business that's
a that's that's you like you did that
you helped do that
and we often as entrepreneurs forget
that so if you built and scaled a team
even just one person on your team
somebody doing you
use the first person we hire somebody to
do admin work typically right they're
very behind the scenes and so I think it
becomes your job to then show the person
who's working behind the scenes how the
work that they're doing is leading to a
Major Impact if you're up front and
you're getting all the accolades and
you're doing the speeches and you're
getting the books and you're making the
videos and you're doing the Selfies and
people are telling you how amazing you
are cool
it's great I mean it it feels amazing
and then think about how can you bring
that back to your team as well and let
them know that they're a part of this
that they created something meaningful
because I think when when you can when
they can attach meaning to their work
there's going to be they're gonna be a
lot happier they're going to give you a
better result they're gonna
they're gonna have more connection to
the work that they're doing and they
feel like they're living out their
purpose as well not everybody wants to
start a business but everybody wants to
feel like they're doing something
meaningful and oftentimes people are
they just haven't made the connection
because you as a leader me as a leader
we haven't done a good enough job in
showing them the impact that their work
is having
so the why becomes everything when you
have a strong enough why you can
overcome and endure anyhow
if you're stuck in the house because
you're afraid how do you get the courage
to push through figure out a strong
enough why
and if you consistently tap into your
own why if you consistently show your
customers why you're doing what you're
doing and if you consistently show your
team
the why of the impact that they're
having I think that's a recipe for
Success also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five use your knowledge
nothing happens until you do something
your life doesn't change your business
doesn't change your situation nothing
changes nothing changes that means
nothing gets better until you decide to
do something this is where a lot of
entrepreneurs get stuck is that we're so
obsessed with learning and it's great
learning is amazing and watching videos
is amazing and going to events is
awesome and reading books and learning
is just awesome but
it's easy to get stuck in our head and
feel like the fact that we learn
something got inspired got motivated is
enough
it's not enough until you go and do
something your life doesn't change until
you do something and so I've seen a lot
of people who who just seminar hop who
go from one person seminar to the next
person seminar to the next person
seminar and you go and you celebrate and
you write a whole notebook full of ideas
but then if nothing's changed in their
life
and listen that's better than the per
than most people most people are just
trapped most people do not like their
life at all most people are not
investing anything in education and
learning and improving so at least it's
a step up from there but it's not where
you ultimately want to be
the difference in where you are now and
where you could be in a year two years
five years Etc is not just what you've
learned it's the action that you've
taken it's learning something and then
immediately applying and the ability to
be a fast starter and build momentum I
think will make an incredible shift
forward for you as a new skill to learn
this year so for example I just came
back from a crazy number of events I was
recording
a VR version of built to serve in
Arizona which was awesome and then I
went to two back-to-back events where I
was invited to be a guest speaker and
sit in on the events of uh one year to
pay 25 000 to be there and the other
he'd be a hundred thousand dollars to be
there the 100K event was a lot smaller
more intimate than the 25k event but
still highly successful entrepreneurs in
the room carrying a person development
lots of speakers and I had a binder full
of notes right as I learned something as
I want to apply something I'm writing it
down feverishly and
at the end of that week it was intense
you know I mean some of the notes for
example on my last day I went for coffee
with a guy who'd sold his business for
over 200 million dollars and he picked
me up from my hotel and we went to his
his compound not just his house and
spent a couple hours there and then he
drove me to the airport and these are
the kinds of people who are at these
events and so if you talk about people
who had built and sold nine-figure
businesses uh there's a lot of wisdom
there's a lot of learning I'm trying to
soak up as much as I can and extract
from his brain into mine and and take as
many notes as possible and I remember
sitting on my airplane ride home
and just being one incredibly grateful
for all the awesome humans that I met
and the advice that I got and then
feeling overwhelmed I've got so many
notes just from this past week I've got
so many notes
I don't know what to do next
and so what I what I used my time on the
airplane there was no direct home
there's no direct flight home from
Phoenix to Toronto and so I had a lot of
airplane time and I used that time to
map out what I was gonna do next
the worst thing you can do is just go
get inspired by anything with an event
the book a podcast a video you just get
inspired and then you fall back into
your regular routine you get so
overwhelmed by so many things that then
nothing happens you get excited but then
overwhelmed and then nothing happens and
you fall back into your regular life but
the best thing you do is take some kind
of immediate action so one of the things
as an example that this guy who sold his
business for 200 million dollars said
was have a single most important number
what is what is the most important
number that would drive your business
forward
and align all your businesses around
that and so everybody on the team has a
has a single most important number
they're working towards and his
structure was most important number and
then the drivers underneath it and then
the action steps that you had to pick so
whatever you could Workshop it right now
think about what's the single most
important number for your business right
now what are the three drivers that then
make that up so to help get you that
number there's three things the most
important things that you can do to help
you focus and then underneath those
drivers are the action steps that you're
going to take this is his methodology
and I liked it I'd never heard of it
before I liked it
um he's writing a book on it and so he
gave me the first draft of the book from
able to be able to read and he said hey
I'm happy to hop on a call with you
um for two hours to walk you through the
process and how you can apply it to your
company whether you know it's you by
yourself you with Nina
we'll do a zoom together and I'll help
you through this like this is amazing
right like yes I love this
uh it's like when when can we do it he's
like I'm I'm busy and I'm traveling
whatever and so you know two and a half
weeks out
from when I left is when when we're
gonna do it I'm grateful and it's
awesome but that's too long and so I'm
of course not saying no to being on the
zoom and getting his wisdom but I need
to do something now because I don't want
to just I don't want to wait two and a
half weeks right like stop being in the
waiting business so
I just started so on the plane ride I
came up with my some most important
numbers for me and for the team and how
to organize it and then when I got home
I talked to Nina about it and we started
working it and planning it and creating
Google Docs around it and starting to
tell the team about it and restructuring
my meetings around it and making some
changes even though I don't have the
model I haven't talked to him yet we
haven't gone in deep we haven't done our
two hour session and I'm sure after we
talk I'm gonna have to make some more
changes too that he's gonna look at what
I did and say hopefully some of it was
right and that some of it was wrong and
I need to tweak it and that's fine but
the most important thing is that I took
some immediate action that I took this
binder full of notes and ideas that that
are inspiring but then got overwhelming
to say what am I going to work on when I
get home and
eighty percent of the things in that
notebook don't have to happen
right I think if you read a book you
don't need to apply everything in the
book you just need to apply something to
start making a difference if I have
every video that I make you just apply
one thing to your life and it makes a
difference for you that's all you need
right and so the willingness
to stop
learning
and and start applying
is is hard but is important the
willingness to put down a book if you're
reading the book and you're getting a
lot from it and you think of an idea to
apply to your your life for your
business stop reading the book and go do
something on that idea
if you're watching a video listen to a
podcast you get it you get inspiration
stop the video stop this if something
came to you while I'm talking stop press
pause on the video and go do something
on that idea and maybe you never even
come back to the video cool you've done
something that's more important right
like where you are now to where you're
going to be in a year is going to be the
sum of the actions that you've taken the
inspired actions and the inspiration can
come from the books and the videos and
the conferences and podcasts and events
but just inspiration alone is not enough
it's the action it's inspired action to
go and do something and so it's
something I'm constantly reminding
myself of and
as you make your path down personal
development and growth and learning
entrepreneurship it becomes very easy to
get sucked into the Trap and let me just
quickly explain why when you're learning
everything is possible when you're at an
event or you're watching a video
everything is possible it's like yeah
man
create this and I can build that and I
could be up here and I can serve so many
people everything is possible and it's
such an exciting place to live in you
know that Visionary inside us that wants
to change the world and other people are
doing it and you're you're trapped
you're not trapped you're locked into
that zone and it's exciting right
everything is possible
and then when it gets to taking action
everything becomes scary
you're judging yourself for not being
good enough you don't know how it's
going to work out you're afraid the
first step is going to be a bad First
Step you're it's just all of the fears
and the doubts and the and the
insecurities come flooding back in
and it's easy to
eliminate all of that all of those fears
insecurities by going and learning
something else
like oh if I learned that then oh yeah
everything's possible again
right it becomes an addiction we're
addicted to the learning and growing and
the the knowledge
because it makes us feel good
but what you need to start getting into
is the action is a service right like
get addicted to serving people get
addicted to help them people and that
will not come until you take the ideas
that you come up with and the knowledge
that you've figured out
and apply it
the best thing you can do whenever
you've learned something is to apply it
and I call it the two percent difference
what is the first two percent that you
need to act on
stop the videos put down the book
and just do something on the first two
percent expect it to suck expect not to
get results but build momentum
when you start building momentum when
you turn yourself from being a knowledge
machine into a momentum machine that's
when you start serving that's when you
start helping that's when you start
building a life that you want that's
where the Fulfillment comes that's where
the money comes everything
is on the other side of taking your
knowledge and turning it into inspired
action rule number six start small I
think big act small think big you got a
big dream a big goal a big mission some
big thing that you want to get done
that's where we love being as
entrepreneurs right we love thinking
about the big future and what we could
build and it is amazing and exciting but
it can also be overwhelming it can be
stressful it can be hurtful to our own
self-esteem because
tell me if this happened to you you've
got this big idea and big goal
and it's exciting to think about it but
then it also becomes scary and it
becomes impossible and it becomes
something that someone like you can't do
and then we get overwhelmed by the
details and then we can't
do anything about it because it feels
too big and to execute it we need a team
or we need venture capital and we need
investors and we need better people
around us and we need more skills and
all of these doubts and insecurities
creep in does that sound familiar is
that you
certainly is me
you know I want to solve the world's
biggest problem people don't believe
themselves enough
and anytime I think even close to that
scale it's instantly well how am I going
to do that
how am I gonna do that I know we're
close
and so the thing that's really helped me
is think big but then act small
because the biggest thing that most
people are missing I'm missing you're
missing it's just momentum biggest thing
we're missing is just we're not we're
not doing enough because thinking big
and having a big idea is amazing but
that alone is not enough you have to go
you got to do the work and we're so
worried about the work being perfect
right you're so worried about the first
thing being amazing
and it won't be
and this is a hard lesson that I learned
when I was uh in my early 20s in my
first business and we lost a 40 million
dollar deal because I was trying to be
perfect
and I spent the whole summer work on
this perfect plane
and I lost the deal and I'm a recovering
perfectionist and I think seeing your
perfectionist really just means you're
afraid right you're afraid of it not
being good enough you're afraid of
launching something and people
seeing it and judging you or you're
afraid of launching it and then not seen
it nobody caring right we're afraid of
being seen and not being seen both at
the same time we're afraid I said the
answer is to do something immediate
action I've been helping people in my
movement makers program
get going on YouTube and now on Tick
Tock and the amount of indecision that
people have around creating their first
video
right what should I wear what should I
say what should I open the line be what
should my thumbnail be what kind of gear
should I use what kind of camera what
kind of microphone what kind of
fill in the blank right all the things
that just prevent you from taking action
where the answer is just film honestly
like just just get something up look I'm
filming this video on my phone walking
down the street
I didn't sleep that well last night
and uh getting some sunshine on my face
and just pressing record and going
and I'm doing the best I can with what I
have
and that's what you need to do is just
get it started because best plan that
you can come up with right now is
nowhere close to the plan that will help
you win
you know the plan that you come up with
right now is not going to be the one
that works because you don't have all
the information and so the idea that you
can plan
what the end looks like and the path to
get there is impossible so we spend our
best energy
planning and thinking instead of
actually doing
a big problem
and so it starts with okay you've got
this big idea awesome now what are you
going to do today about it today there's
a couple of hacks that I want to share
with you and I think can help so the
first is a two percent difference and
the two percent difference says instead
of planning for a hundred percent you
work on the first two percent so what is
that first superset that's all you need
to work on what's the first two percent
so if you're thinking about YouTube or
making a tick tock you're thinking about
a health Journey you're thinking about
whatever it is for your business that
you want to launch what's the first two
percent
I just start building momentum so you
know if you want to make a YouTube video
go film a video just take out your phone
and film a video just like I am right
now you want to get started on Tick Tock
cool same thing
flip your flip your phone the other way
vertical and start making your video you
want to start a health Journey cool
you know we get so stuck on
figuring out what The Perfect Workout is
going to be right have you ever done
this well am I going to do hit am I
going to do cardio how many weights are
going to do am I am I gonna am I gonna
hurt myself do I need to hire a trainer
what new equipment do I need to buy you
know we just get stuck in all this
planning mode instead of doing
just do anything just go for a walk
do five push-ups you know do a couple
burpees whatever whatever comes to mind
it doesn't matter what you do it's
matter that you're doing something
that's the big difference it doesn't
matter the specific action that you're
taking who matters that you're starting
to build some kind of momentum that
you're doing something
that's the most important thing because
if you
get up and you do something every day
you're going to find that you start
making some tremendous progress towards
things
and so two percent difference is to
teach yourself that you go from an idea
to some kind of immediate action that
we're doing something right away on it
we're not planning for 100 but we're
going for that first two percent the
next thing is just expect the suck at
the beginning
you know we expect to be great out of
the gate for some reason you expect your
idea to work you expect that you're
going to have the skills or who you
expect you're going to create something
amazing you won't just expect the second
to start
it doesn't mean that you suck as a human
it just means that you don't have the
skill set yet and that's okay that's
normal and that's totally okay that's
fine
go back and watch my first video it was
pretty embarrassing go back and watch
anybody's first anything and it's and it
sucks
it's normal
so if you expect to be great and then
you try something and you can't do it
then you feel really bad about yourself
but if you expect it to suck and then
and then you're just anything above
complete terrible sucking
then you're good then you've won
and so
apply the two percent difference
and then just expect to suck to suck at
the start and then you keep going
So for anybody there who's afraid to
take action who you know you have these
big Ideas big goals Big Dreams big
things you want to do
but it just seems so Out Of Reach and it
seems impossible and it seems that you
can't do it and it's never going to work
you know and you're stuck in
overthinking
over planning over estimating over just
over over just stuck in your head
and it's crazy how quickly we can go
from being excited by something
to then almost instantly overwhelmed by
it
you know and so you need to have the big
dream you need to have the big goal that
that should get you
out of bed and excited it's like yes
this is the change I want to make in the
world amazing
and at the same time you need a
incredibly small action plan just to get
going
because you've got the great heart and
the big dream and the big mission the
only thing you're missing is momentum
rule number seven meet new people your
environment creates your energy
when you are at home and you are down
and you're out and you just stay home
and you never get any fresh air and you
never get people around you to push you
and make you feel like things are
possible then you stay stuck
and when you get outside or when you go
to an event and when you meet people
even if you're not there to learn even
if you haven't picked up anything at
that event just the fact that you got
out and you met people and you change
your environment and you got some
sunshine can make a world of difference
it is
incredibly difficult to be an
entrepreneur
it's hard
it's hard not just in that you're you
know not seeing results at the beginning
and you're trying to figure out how to
make money but it's also hard that
you're by yourself
you know and you doubt yourself and your
insecurities and fears and you don't
know if it's going to work out or not
it's really hard and so when you're
stuck doing everything on your own and
then the fears and the doubts in skirt
is free pain when you're by yourself at
home
that's the path down to the scary Lane
you know that's the path down to anxiety
and stress and depression and it's why a
big reason why we stay stuck and while
we start and stop and start and stop and
start and stop
and and can't stay consistent have you
ever been on that entrepreneur roller
coaster where you're motivated and
excited and things are great one day and
the next day you wake up and it's kind
of not so great anymore does that happen
to you it happened to me a lot that's
for sure in the early days I mean I quit
on my business partner because I wasn't
getting results and I just felt like a
loser felt like a total idiot because
nothing was working out
um
it's the worst day of my life it wasn't
I didn't have the heart or the ambition
to do great things or didn't believe in
the company it's just it wasn't working
out nothing was working out
I felt terrible about it
and the big reason why is because I was
alone I was by myself I was alone
I didn't tell my friends I mean I guess
I had a business partner but I felt bad
talking about it with with him and
I stay stuck
and so it took me a bunch of years to
figure out
these things that I'm about to share
with you today about some hacks that
I've used to help me maintain the
momentum
so let's dive in the first is every
morning I go for a believe walk
and the belief walk is just me going
outside and selling a rain or snow here
in Canada I go for a believe walk and on
that walk
it's just a way to start my day because
no matter how great a day I might have
today tomorrow I wake up and it's
another day even today was rough I only
slept two and a half hours or something
last night so it's a very non-typical
day energy not where it needs to be or
usually is in the morning and so first
thing let's get up
and you know give us our a little bit of
Grace it may not be as great a day as as
we usually do but I'm gonna go for my
believe walk and just getting outside
just getting some fresh air on my face
just
you know having some sun with me just
not being in my my home
already starts to lighten the mood
already starts to give me more energy
and so every day I go for a believe walk
you know unless I am just completely
incapacitated I wake up get some sun on
my face wherever I am and get my belief
walking just think about what's the kind
of day I want to have you know what's my
intention for the day I'm trying to set
that up two try to go to events and to
the idea of you know buy tickets to
things
it could be things that you don't care
about but it could also be things that
you actually you know you're going to be
around some people and every time I go
away to an event this is why you know a
pandemic has been hard because he's just
been sitting inside but every time that
I get to go away to some kind of event
whether I learn something there or not
from the speakers or the people there
I always come back with Renewed Energy
with renewed excitement with renewed
ideas even if you just go on if you were
going on vacations you know you go on a
vacation and you sit on the beach and I
hate the beach you know I hate sitting
there on the beach go and sit on the
beach for one day and then all of a
sudden get bored of sitting on the beach
I want to do something and so I'm then
instantly pulling out my notebook and
coming up with ideas or reading books
and you come away refreshed even though
the goal wasn't necessarily business but
you get new ideas for your business when
you get out of your routine your your
you know the routine is great but when
you feel like you're stuck
then adding a little bit of variety to
it can really help this is the balance
that we have to do as entrepreneurs we
love variety we love new we love we love
trying all sorts of new things but if we
don't stay consistent on something we'll
never accomplish our goals but if all we
do is do the same thing constantly and
we stay consistent on doing the same
thing we end up getting bored and hating
our business and now we just bought
ourselves a job so it's that constant
balance where if you haven't had any
variety for a while you need to add more
variety in and if you haven't had
consistency for a while you need to add
more consistency with this ebb and flow
that's part of being an entrepreneur
that time I think you need to build in
so
just scheduling time so you have your
believe walks at least I do every every
morning to set me up for the day and
then schedule in time to be able to go
off and
just just not be at home you know
whether it's a conference or an event a
vacation just something to refresh my
mind
and then the third thing is just join a
community
it was one of the biggest things that I
missed was I had no Community I was
doing it all by myself and I'm being
introverted and being shy I don't
naturally seek out community community
and talking to people it's not something
that that is normally in my mind and I'm
nervous you know going up and talking to
people so it's harder for someone like
me and maybe someone like you to join a
community but man what a difference it
makes
I think of movement makers and this is
really the program I wish I had when I
was getting started you know movement
makers is yes advice for me and we meet
every two weeks and talk about your the
movement you're trying to build and
everything you're trying to create but
more than that is a connection Community
to each other that
if you want to be a thought leader you
are not by yourself think about what
you're trying to do if you think about
what I was trying to do like I'm the
only one who I know who's trying to do
this you know who are your friends who
are trying to make YouTube videos who
else is walking through this Mom making
content
so who do you know who know who's going
to want to do probably nobody and who
who do you know who's doing what you
want to do at a high level and who's
ambitious and hungry probably nobody
right like you are probably the one who
is the most kind optimistic ambitious
person around you and so when you start
to get around other people who are like
that as well man what a huge difference
it makes and so you can look at Movie
Makers if you want to be a thought
leader but just in general to find a
community find a community of people who
are doing the thing that you are trying
to do even if they haven't done it yet
but they're ambitious and they're hungry
and they're trying to do it
change your life
certainly business is really hard and
you know this if you're watching this
video you made it this far you know what
you know it's hard
the environment that you're around
is only partially supporting you and
when you can shake it up when you can
get outside and go for walks get some
sun on your face when you can get out of
your home and go to events and just be
around other people who are doing things
and when you can join a community of
people who are trying to do something
similar to what you're doing it can make
all the difference in the world
you've got a great idea
you're doing it for the right reason
you've got a noble cause and if you feel
like you have those energy dips where
one day you're on top of the world and
it's all exciting and then the next day
you kind of wake up and you're you're in
a rut
if that right continues on you know for
days or weeks it's a sign not that
you're on the that this isn't the right
for you it's just a sign that you need
to add a little more variety and remind
yourself of who you are rule number
eight decide on your mission get rid of
your 10-year goals and create a mission
instead I think a lot of people are so
worried about where they're going to be
in a year and five years in 10 years we
do these goals planning actually you
ever gone through that you've ever gone
through a goal planning exercise goal
said and exercise at events you read a
book says we're going to be in a year in
five years or 10 years
and the more that I've thought about it
the more that I've gone through the
exercise is the more I realized it's not
important
that's not helpful it's not where we
want to be because you don't know what
you're capable of in a five-year period
a 10-year period think about who you
were five years ago take today's date
and subtract five years think about that
person
could you have predicted where you are
right now could the person you were five
years ago have any degree of confidence
is plan a life for who you are right now
this is like there's no way there's no
way not if you're growing not if you're
learning not if you're improving if
you're watching this channel then you're
somebody who is learning and growing and
improving and so you had no idea what
you're capable of five years ago and so
what makes you think that it's any
different now that you can plan for the
next five years the only way that you
can create a 10-year plan for yourself
is if you are not growing and you're in
a really static life you know like if
you're going to be a lawyer and you're
going to work your way up and be a
senior partner at the law firm and that
that takes a certain amount of time cool
you could you could plan that out
that's a pretty boring life
you know chances are if you're watching
this video you don't want that life that
you want to create new and build new and
that requires
being the being flexible to jump off of
your 10-year goals right it's not that
it's wrong to have goals goals can work
they can be motivating but
your goals right now a reflection of who
you currently are
that's the problem whatever goal you set
right now is a reflection of who you
currently are and the more that you are
growing as a human and the more that the
world involves and new technology comes
out and New Opportunities arise
the longer Horizon you put out the less
accurate it's going to be
and so instead of worrying about having
a 10-year goal replace it with a mission
the problem of a 10-year goal is you
could actually hit your 10-year goal
it's just way small compared to what
you're capable of
and so the answer is have a mission
what's your mission what are you trying
to accomplish like what's the big
problem that you're trying to solve and
then wake up every day trying to attack
that mission as opposed to worrying
about where you're going to be in 10
years this might flip a lot of goal
setting on its head that might flip a
lot of what you've been told or taught
or thought on its head and listen if
having that 10-year goal works for you
and is actually motivating cool keep
keep with it keep going if it's helping
you use it but if you feel like there's
something more or you feel like 10 year
goal is not enough you don't feel
motivated when you look at your 10-year
goal from two years ago it doesn't
appeal to you anymore it's probably why
you know you're you're growing too
quickly the problem is not your goals
the problems that you grew too much the
10-year goal was great for who you were
three years ago
you're not that person anymore you've
grown too much it's that's that's not a
reason to feel bad that's really feeling
amazing you know you've grown you've
outgrown yourself you've shed your skin
you now turn into the next generation of
you
and So my answer is admission what's the
mission what are you trying to
accomplish you know so for me I want to
solve the world's biggest problem
entrepreneurs and you know people don't
believe in themselves people don't
believe in themselves and I don't
believe myself enough you don't believe
in yourself enough nobody nobody you
know walking out here believes in
themselves enough we just we don't
believe in ourselves enough
and I want to I want to solve that
problem and I'm never going to solve
that problem and I wake up every day
trying to solve that problem and why
it's so helpful to have a mission like
that is
because it gives you something to fight
for every day and there's always
something new that can come out that can
help you with that and there's always
opportunities that I think guys the
amount of things that I've seen and that
happened in the past 10 years if you
look at 10 years ago
where was I on YouTube I started in
April 2009 so it was early in on my
career on YouTube I had a couple hundred
subscribers there's no way I would have
said it'd be here
there's no way just with the with the
impact I've had with the people I've met
with the even just the confidence to sit
here guys I would have been so terrified
to sit in a park making a video
terrified
of who's watching me who's judging me
who's coming around the corner who's
behind there maybe you know looking at
me and judging me you know they've been
this would have been impossible so the
person I was 10 years ago would have
never even thought of this as a
possibility
and now it's it's it's normal
it's not a problem
right how quickly that we can grow
and so you can with a mission it's a
problem you're trying to solve and then
as you develop new skill sets and
improve mindsets and better belief
systems and as you know the market and
Technology evolves and opportunities
arise as you keep going and building
momentum there will be new things that
you can go off and do that you never
thought were possible but it's always in
service of the mission
so how do you find the mission well
that's your purpose for me and your
purpose comes from your pain so whatever
you struggled the most with is the thing
you want to help other people through
and so I struggled so much to believe in
myself in the early days of my business
and quit like I quit for one day on my
business in worst day of my life and I
just want to make the path a little bit
easier for others how do I keep going
people ask me how do you how do you keep
going how do you keep making content
have you made I don't know thirteen
thousand fifteen thousand I don't know
how many videos I've made it's crazy how
many videos we've done
I only slept two and a half hours last
night it was a really rough night why
get up and keep making content because
I'm on a mission
because this means something to me
whether four people watch this video or
four million people watch this video
I'm hoping that
this video in some way is a video that
moves a needle just a little bit for
somebody watching maybe it's you maybe
this is the video that you decide I'm
gonna I'm gonna do something I'm gonna
find my mission I'm gonna stop creating
10-year goals and stop over planning and
over preparing and overthinking and over
strategizing and over doubting myself
and just go do something like maybe
today this is the video or maybe I make
another video today that accomplishes
that like that's that's my goal that's
why I do what I do that's what gives me
the energy to wake up when every bone in
my body is saying you know sleep
don't do the difficult thing
and it's easy because I'm on a mission
and so what's yours what did you
struggle with the most as a human
and if you can connect to that
you can think about all the people who
currently are struggling with the thing
that you struggled with
you know you're not done growing you're
not done learning you're still improving
there's still a long ways to go your by
no means perfect neither am I
but you're a lot further ahead than you
used to be and there's a lot of people
right now who are right now stuck where
you used to be
I didn't know what to do they don't know
where to turn they don't have anybody
who believes in them they don't have any
hope they don't have any strategies they
think they're stocked they think they're
stuck
in your story your message your content
you reaching out you could make the
difference for them
if you actually believe that it's going
to just change the energy with which you
show up and open you up to amazing new
opportunities that again you can't
predict 10 years in advance
so it's a it's a challenge it's a call
to action today
if you love setting your 10-year goals
and it works for you amazing keep going
do do what works for you but if you feel
like
you're judging yourself against them if
you feel like they're not working for
you if you feel like you're six months
in and you already want to change it the
problem is not that it's a 10-year goal
the problem is that you have already
outgrown what what you're capable of
you've already outgrown it six months in
a year and
and the thing that you want to grow is
the mission
to have a have a goal have a purpose so
big
that you never solve it and you wake up
every day trying to solve it rule number
nine be willing to walk alone the people
you're surrounded by matters your
environment right now the people you
hang out with
it's all been perfectly designed to keep
you stuck to keep you small to keep you
where you are to keep your growth curve
slow
you know we have these negative voices
in our heads but
somebody put those voices in your head
you telling yourself that you suck and
you can't do it that's that's not your
voice you know when you're when you're
born
everything is possible think about even
when you were a kid your dreams your
goals what you wanted to be what you
wanted to do I remember I wanted to be a
baseball player in the summer and then
via fireman or a police officer in the
winter in the off season
and think about what happens to those
dreams now some of them might have been
too too uh We've outgrown them you know
why they want to be a police officer
here because I saw a police officer on
the street or something but some of them
we outgrow but a lot of times we just
also not just outgrow the idea of it but
it gets knocked out of us you know that
sense of hope and potential and what we
can do and where we can go and what we
can learn and who we can be they get it
gets knocked out of us
by our parents by our teachers or the
people around us by Society by school it
gets knocked out of us
and that is not good
you know it sucks
your environment has been perfectly
designed to keep you stuck to keep you
safe and to keep you small but that is
not your voice
that is not your voice and so part of
the work is finding your voice
and being willing to go down the path
that nobody else is going down one of
the reasons why entrepreneurship is so
hard is that people are
feel of their stock have you felt stuck
have you felt like you're the only one
who's doing what you're doing do you
feel like nobody understands you nobody
gets you nobody supports you nobody
nobody's here to tell you what what you
can do in a loving way forward
nobody is as optimistic or as hopeful or
as ambitious as you
and it's not that those people don't
exist it's just not in your environment
and
it's easy to stay being that
big fish in the small pond you know it's
easy to say stuck being the person who's
constantly pouring and loving and caring
and giving in to others but at what
point do you decide that you need more
for yourself as well
because when you can be around people
who are doing bigger things that push
you that make you see things are
possible in a whole new way it just
changes everything
when I got started as an entrepreneur
I had I had business partners so that
was really helpful
but apart from that I I isolated myself
I didn't see my friends I had no money I
was embarrassed I was ashamed I was
alone
which made it really difficult for me to
wake up every day and go do the thing
that I wanted to do and and just took
its toll on my self-worth and
self-esteem you know that this isn't
working I would poured so much energy
and love and heart into and it's just
not working out
and one of the things that helped was
getting a mentor
and
over the years I've had a bunch of
mentors who've helped me with different
things and I've realized in that process
that I'm not a dummy
that I'm not stupid
and that when I have somebody to guide
me and help me when I'm around other
people
who are going through similar things it
helps Lift Me Up
and you'll have moments where you'll
have people who are way ahead of you
but it's not only the people who are way
ahead of you
you know just being around people who
are happy
how many of the people around you are
happy and optimistic and positive to
speak around people who are ambitious
and going after their dream just being
around those people starts to change
things so let me share two examples
one
uh if we're looking at pointing up
learning for some reason a lot more than
us I recently came back from Phoenix
Arizona I was speaking at a couple
events in one of the groups you had to
pay a hundred thousand dollars to be in
it's a pretty high level group
pretty impressive people and on the last
day I had breakfast coffee with one of
the members at his home and calling it a
home is an understatement is a it's like
four homes in one home it's a compound
and
this guy had just sold his business for
over 200 million dollars in hanging with
him and seeing how he reacted to things
and getting some feedback on my business
I I came away not just with ideas and
what to do but just inspiration and
motivation and excitement and energy is
like wow
this guy's just playing the whole other
level
and coming home it's like I'm on the
airplane I'm on fire you know let's
let's get to work let's start building
the Empire let's start having a bigger
impact and reaching even more people
but it's not every day that you can kind
of go hang out with people who sold the
business for 200 million dollars right
like oh that's easy for you you know you
met that person what am I supposed to do
find peers
you find communities you find clubs
and that's why I created movement makers
which is awesome and every two weeks we
meet and connect and
I'm helping
thought leaders for on the way up build
their content build their movement get
their message out to the world
and the biggest part of it is I think
not being able to learn from me and hang
out but being able to be with other
people who are doing something similar
that
we do challenges where people are making
content together and going live together
and the amount of times people have come
in have never gone live or afraid to
make their first video and then somebody
says hey I'll help do it with you
let's go live together
it makes such a difference
who's doing that for you who's taking
your ideas and saying hey let's go do
that together I'll help you
and so joining some kind of community
and they don't have to be people who are
way far ahead of you
you know you may not be connecting with
the 200 million dollar entrepreneur but
just people who are on the same path who
who are lifting others up who are
pouring into you who are ambitious as
well just just being around them makes a
huge difference
a guy an entrepreneur invested into
Alex has been
struggling with not having entrepreneur
friends and connections and being the
the you know lonely entrepreneurs I said
just go go join some entrepreneur events
go to some entrepreneur meetups and go
to conferences that are happening in the
city and he just recently went to one I
said listen your goal here is not to not
to learn from the speakers
you won't be impressed by the speakers
you'll you'll you already know most of
the content your goal is for the energy
and connection your goal should be to
talk to 25 people
each day there's two days so go talk to
50 people and then out of that to be
able to have a connection with with a
couple people that you want to follow up
with and so you know tomorrow he's going
downtown to meet one of the
entrepreneurs that he met at the event
that's much more powerful than learning
because he knows all the content he
consumes my content he watches the
videos he's he's a learner
point of going there is not to learn
from the speakers the point is to go and
meet and connect with other people
and so join some kind of community for
whatever the thing is that you're trying
to do so that you you're willing to walk
alone but hopefully you don't have to
and then last but not least I'd suggest
just consuming content
that's what really helped me it still
helps me if I'm learning from Elon Musk
or Oprah Winfrey or whoever it is
feature their videos
sometimes if I wake up and I the energy
is not there I'll I'll go for a morning
walk which always helps and then I'll
feed my mind with
with the video
from something on my own channel I still
make the videos for me because I want
them and I need them every day as a
reminder
to think bigger to play a bigger game
that what I'm doing is possible that it
can't happen that others have proved it
and that I just need to believe more
it is scary and hard to run your own
race
and a lot of people will doubt you along
the way and tell you that it's not
possible even if it's in a loving way
it's not possible that you can't do it
and we often then lead to doubt in
ourselves
and that voice comes in and says that we
can't do it
and so the answer is to start to shift
the environment
to start to eliminate the people who are
creating those negative thoughts around
us to start to try to get some mentors
to help teach and learn to try to join a
community of people who are just as
ambitious as we are trying to accomplish
great things and to be around the
content of people who Inspire us to want
to go off and be amazing
you can't do that
your environment's been perfectly
designed to keep you where you are but
you don't have to stay stuck where you
are
Where You Are
at the end of the life it doesn't have
to be where you are right now the
difference is going to be how much are
you changing up the environment and the
people you're hanging out with and Rule
Number 10 the last one before our very
special bonus Club is wanted badly
enough what stops us from chasing our
obsession is the Judgment that it's
wrong we feel that it's wrong to pour so
much time and energy and effort into
something especially if it's not working
out and paying dividends and results
it's yes the people around us telling us
that what are you doing it's crazy stop
doing it but it's also us it's our own
voice in our own head saying can I do
this am I wasting my time is this thing
even worth doing and then what ends up
happening is you regret not taking the
action right we don't regret the things
that we do often It's usually the things
that we don't do the actions untuck the
goals that you had that you are too
afraid to do something on
and that Obsession that we felt was
wrong think of this in my life I used to
judge myself a lot on this and I would
get obsessed like one of the things that
I think now is a core strength of mine
as I get obsessed on something then it
has to happen I was at an event and uh
it was a YouTube event and there was a
really really big famous guy runs a
bunch of events pretty well known and I
was on him for you to start a YouTube
channel did you got to start a YouTube
channel and I was just on him on him on
him on him fast forward to today is
about three years ago he's got a YouTube
channel he's got six figures and
subscribers
um and he's on my mind because I was
texting him some thumbnail ideas this
morning and I just I was on him I
couldn't let it go like this has to
happen you you need to do this and it
just felt right and that energy and that
conviction is one of the things that
helped move the needle and you've got
ideas and energy and great things in you
and products you want to create and
services you want to launch and people
that you want to serve and help and it
and trust it and listen to it the indeed
the thing that's in your heart that is
this little it's a it's a it's a muscle
to develop the courage to follow the
obsession because
a lot of our brain takes over and tells
us to be safe and be practical and do
the smart thing and make sure that
you're paying your bills and all of that
and yes of course you have to learn how
to pay your bills
but where we taught the courage muscle
where we taught the obsession must where
we taught to to you've got this dream
that is noble and worthy where are we
taught to actually follow through on and
at least do something about it so over
the years it's taken me a long time and
and the goal with this video is to try
to help it
not take as long for you over the years
I used to judge myself for wanting
something
and just thinking about it constantly
and sometimes those ideas lead to
long-term projects look at my YouTube
channel how my main channel it's been 13
years
13 years
[Music]
oh you know 13 000 videos something like
that not all of them are public
how what because because I'm obsessed I
want to I want to bring more value I
want to create more content I want to
impact more entrepreneurs it's a how do
you how do you stay consistent on
something because I want to do it
because I'm obsessed about it because I
feel like it's going to matter even at
the beginning when I had 25 subscribers
in my first year and 7 000 subscribers
after five years like how do you keep
going well I was obsessed with trying to
make content that I thought would help
some people and that's been a long-term
Obsession there's something a lot
shorter term
um I remember I was on writing my book
your one word also built to serve both
of my books
were flowing through me and there was
every reason why I shouldn't do it your
one word I finished writing the book on
my cruise I was on vacation with my wife
and we're enjoying our vacation and it
was flowing through it was like I need
to I need to do this and so while she
slept I I wrote my book and while she uh
went to a show or or did some something
at the spa I finished writing the book
we still did the excursions and saw the
cities together but the second part of
the cruise I was I was just in it was
flowing through me I had to get this
thing done otherwise I know I'm going to
regret it for build to serve I wrote it
when I was on my tour in 2019 and I did
not have time to write a book I did not
have time I mean I was behind that
everything where we're traveling every
four days to New City I'm presenting it
just I did not have time to do this
I did not have time and yet it was
flowing through me and like I'm obsessed
I have to get this done I have to have
to have to have to get this done
and
with experience and age and time I've
learned to lean in on those things
instead of Judge them where typically
what happens is you come with a good
idea you think it's great it has a lot
of potential and then you immediately
judge it to say well I can't do that I'm
not worthy I'm not good enough I don't
have the skills I don't have the money
uh why am I still spending all this time
on thinking about some idea that that I
could never do we instantly judge it and
maybe you do a little bit of work on it
you start trying and you taste and you
test and you explore a little bit and
then and then what happens if you don't
get immediate results you wake up the
next day or the next week or the next
month and say see I knew you couldn't do
it
you're crazy why would you think you
could do this and instantly talk
ourselves down from it
and what I've learned to try to do and
I'm still
working on it is to listen to that
intuition and listen to that gut and and
it's right and it's Noble and great
ideas flow through you and stop judging
them and so the process I use
is one that great ideas flow through me
so just believe the great ideas flow
through you this is how you eliminate
the overthinking and and your brain
getting in the way you come with a great
idea your brain gets in the way how do
you get out of that great ideas flow
through just trust a great idea the fact
that it came to you as long as you're in
a positive optimistic energy you know
serving state if you're feeling jealous
or rage or you know if somebody cuts you
off in in line I'm in my car right now
we're parked but
if somebody cuts you off when you're
you're upset maybe maybe the idea that
comes to you is not a good idea but if
you're feeling positive and encouraged
and optimistic and and serving and want
to help and an idea comes to you trust a
great ideas flow through you just tell
yourself great ideas flow through me and
that at least gives me the courage to
stop overthinking and start doing
something step number two is just get
started start I called the two percent
difference what's the first two percent
we waste our best energy on trying to
plan out 100 of where this company or
idea business is going to grow that's
not the way to do it you'll you'll never
plan it at 100 you have no idea what's
going to happen with this thing and so
instead of spending your best energy
this is the problem you spend your best
energy
I guess we could do that oh yeah here's
how it could work out your energy where
you feel confident and bold you spend
your best energy on research and
planning instead of doing something and
research and planning are important but
it can't be the first step because
you're again wasting your best energy
you wake up the next day you feel like
oh I can't do this so instead your best
energy the first step needs to be the
first two percent you're doing something
you're calling somebody you're booking
something you're creating something when
I had an idea to start a podcast I I
messaged my friend Marcus said we're
going to start a podcast and he said
when tonight what do you mean when
tonight when I'm back from my tour in a
month and a half no we're starting it
tonight
but we don't have the gear what are we
going to talk about and we'll figure it
out I'm going to get back to we're going
to drive to my Airbnb and we're gonna
we're gonna launch our podcast together
tonight it has to happen tonight or it's
not going to happen
right that that becomes a process super
important and step number three is just
expect to suck at the start expect to
suck at the start we expect to be great
for whatever reason at the beginning of
when we're doing our thing right we
expect to be great don't expect to be
great expect to suck expect the first
thing to be terrible for it not to work
out
cheers it's not gonna work out not as
you plan not at the beginning you don't
get on a bike and just ride it you don't
make a video and just crush it right it
doesn't mean that you suck as a person
you just don't have the skill set yet
and by practicing and trying and tasting
and testing you'll get a little bit
better and when you start something and
you expect to be great and then you're
not great you quit
but when you start something and you
expect it to be terrible then anything
above terrible is progress his momentum
is a win and celebrate that celebrate
the fact that you took a step celebrate
the fact that you recorded a video
celebrate the fact that you wrote the
first page in your book celebrate the
fact that you you launched your first
episode of a podcast even though you
don't know what questions to talk about
what questions to ask the formatting all
of that stuff that doesn't matter you
started momentum you celebrate the
momentum and expect the results to suck
at the beginning and if you keep going
you'll learn the skill to get better at
the thing so it's okay to be obsessed
it's okay there's there's a great idea
inside you that you know you want to
work on that you know you need to do
be obsessed on it start small create
something right now apply the two
percent difference trust the great ideas
flow through you expect to expect a suck
at the beginning
and make it because otherwise you look
back on your life at this moment and say
I could have done something back then
and I wish I had
so I have a slightly different take on
meditation and if you've been struggling
with meditation in your life this might
help I first thought believe in the
power of meditation I believe the
science I believe all the studies and I
used to judge myself and feel really bad
about it because I I felt like I
couldn't meditate I would sit there on
the couch or on the pillow or on the bed
or lie down and I never felt anything
when I was meditated I could sit and I
could be present and I could I could I
could do it and then and I could sit
there for 20 minutes and it felt like 20
minutes
but I never felt any different I mean
that was where it started to shift for
me is not that I didn't feel anything in
the moment but never felt any different
coming out and I've meditated with some
of the
the the best meditation teachers
um on the planet and it's never really
led to an impact for me uh in the moment
or afterwards or sustained and I again
would judge myself really harshly like
hey I mean how I want to make this work
how do I make this work I Believe In The
Sciences go and make it work
what I've distilled it down to is into
two parts one is a lot of meditation a
lot of benefits I believe from
meditation are really just about being
present and being Mindful and that is
something that I can do a lot more
naturally than maybe most people and I
don't find a lot of benefit in it
because I'm more there than not so I I'm
85 present 15 future focused and zero
percent past focus when you are thinking
about the past it's usually really
negative way sometimes we like pass Look
Backwards into the past and it's
gratitude and and remembering great
memories and
um you know looking all the great things
we've done but for the most part when
you look backwards it's negative it's
regrets it's I wish I did this or why
did that person do that to me I wish I
had said something different we're we're
looking negatively on our past mostly
through the lens of regret and what you
did or what other people did and when
you're looking forward entrepreneurs
love looking forward and the vision and
the building what you can create and all
the amazing things but a lot of looking
forward is also uncertainty in Stress
and Anxiety in what may happen and what
could happen and what might happen if x
happens and just we're stuck in these
negative Loops a lot of the backwards
thinking is negative through the lens of
regret and a lot of the Forward Thinking
is negative through the lens of anxiety
stress and worry and so that's where hey
if you're present-minded you're going to
be a lot happier you're going to be a
lot more focused right if you're just
thinking about what you should have done
or what might happen to you you're not
actually able to be productive and get
stuff out right now in the present and
so the job becomes how do I stay present
and I think a lot of that is
accomplished through meditation for most
people if you're if you're in a state of
stress thinking about the regret of the
past or anxiety about the future I think
meditation can be incredibly helpful to
help you get back to present even just
focusing on your breath breathe in
breathe out even something as simple as
that can help calm you down and get you
back to the present moment which then
allows you to
be able to be productive uh solve the
problem be happy because you're being
more present so for me that's actually
quite easy I'm in the present uh a lot
more than anywhere else and I used to
think it as a negative a friend of mine
used to make fun of me for having a bad
memory it's like you're such a bad
memory it's like and I later realized I
I don't have a bad memory I I want to
remember what's important to me but two
I'm not living in the past like I don't
care about what happened I'm looking at
right now today I don't know what day it
is I don't know what day it is I don't
know I I know it's 2022 when recording
this I'd have to think about what month
it is
I don't know what I'm doing after
recording this video I don't know what I
did yesterday I don't know what I'm
doing tomorrow let alone once I press
stop on this video I am here with you
this is this is my entire attention is
making this video right now that's it
this is this is the present moment for
me and what I've discovered is
this is meditation
at least the the portion of it where
you're getting back to present moment if
that's one of the main benefits of
meditation then this is meditation for
me I'm only in the present moment right
now being here talking with you guys and
that's it
and I realized that most of my life is
lived like that yes I love planning for
where I'm gonna go but most of my time
isn't spent in planning it's in in
executing in doing and I have to look at
my calendar to see what I'm doing
tomorrow or what I'm doing when somebody
asks me on a Wednesday what's your
weekend gonna look like
weekend I don't even know what I'm doing
in the next hour let alone what I'm
doing this weekend and when people ask
me on a Monday how was your weekend like
I don't know
that was that was that was yesterday
that was two days ago I'm I got stuff to
do right now I'm working on my life
right now and and not just work even
just enjoying even just life even just
me spending time with with my wife or my
son or on a trip it's like let's enjoy
this moment where we're at right now and
so if that's you I would introduce the
idea of hey that's a different
perspective shift like maybe you are
meditating right now and you might be
over judging yourself because if you're
in the present that's one of the biggest
benefits one of my favorite things to do
every morning is I go on a belief walk
and I found when a lot of people would
say oh I get my best ideas when I'm
meditate if I get creative breakthroughs
when I'm meditating part of that that I
believe is hey you've unblocked yourself
from the past and the future the regrets
of the past the stress of the future to
get back to present which then calms you
down to then that should be more
creative and solve the problem I found I
wasn't getting I wasn't really getting
answers I wasn't getting Solutions I
wasn't being very creative of sitting
down lying down and having my body be
still where I get a lot more of my
energy and creativity and ideas when I'm
moving so I get a lot of ideas
when I'm walking so I do a belief walk
every morning which is 30 to 60 minutes
I'll take the dogs out and then I'll go
for a walk usually the Tim Hortons grab
myself a coffee Canadian coffee brain
here and
No Agenda just think about what what am
I doing today you know what what day is
it what I want to accomplish today uh
taking some fresh air get a fresh
perspective and the the act of moving I
find gets my creativity flowing a lot
more I get ideas in the shower you know
when I'm when I'm moving have you got
ideas in the shower that I think that's
meditation maybe it's a different
version of it a different definition of
it but I think that's meditation where
you can calm down when you can focus on
present and you get some great ideas to
come I'm selling my place we just bought
a new house we're selling this place and
the studio looks a little different
normally I'm filming in my car because
we're running some errands or my regular
studio and to get this place ready to
sell you you know we wanted to have a a
place that everybody could connect to
and so what my agent did was make an
office in a different room and I'm
sitting down and I have not sat down for
two years I don't know my last time I
like sat down to actually work and and
you might even notice me like I'm
Shuffling around a little bit like I
like to move normally I'm on a
trampoline and I'm bouncing 20 to 40 000
times a day and I got that because I
would find that when I did phone calls I
would much rather stand up and walk
around the office than just sit down and
so I'm a lot more creative and have a
lot more energy when I'm moving and
maybe that movement in my energy creates
movement in you know brain energy and
capacity and thinking creativity as well
but all of that is my form of meditation
and so anytime that I would challenge
you to at least consider the fact that
anytime that you're present
anytime that you are focused on
something that you can consider that
part of the benefits of meditation
the second part of meditation that I
haven't fully connected to yet and I
don't have a solution for yet is when
you access theta waves and that's
basically when you're bouncing between
conscious and subconscious and where you
feel like
time flies so for me when I sit down or
lie down doing a meditation
if it's 20 minutes it feels like 20
minutes and I don't think I'm hitting
any Theta levels
um I can sit there and be present and
focus on my breath or you know I've
chewed a cookie for half an hour or an
hour and never swallowed it you know
like the focus and the presence I can do
but it still feels like it's 20 minutes
or half an hour or an hour I've never
had a I sat down for an hour and I felt
like it was I was only on for five
minutes
I get that more through the work that
I'm doing I get that more
um I recently did a six hour uh q a with
Tom bilyu's impact community
on his Discord and
it was six hours I didn't go to the
bathroom I didn't take a break I was I
was reading the questions and answering
the questions my throat was burning
didn't even notice it till the end and
had that six hours flew where that felt
if you asked me how long was it I would
have said I don't know it was like 20
minutes half an hour like six hours six
hours later still going and then we
eventually wrapped it up because it
needs to go to dinner
my wife where I said yeah I'm gonna do
this short little q a and turned out to
be six hours
so maybe that's even a better form of
meditation maybe maybe when you're in
your purpose and doing great work and
time flies because you're having fun
maybe that is a better form of
meditation for you if you struggle with
just sitting down and meditating maybe
doing that work is healing you know I
think a lot of people meditate to heal
and I think of a
part of why that could work is because
you're again removing the stress of the
past of the regret of the past and
removing the anxiety and stress of the
future and when your body's all stressed
out it's not going to heal right but
when you get back to present and remove
the stress you create the conditions for
healing in your body
well I remember when I broke my neck in
2019 and I kept doing my tour I kept
staying on it because I wanted to be
around entrepreneurs I wanted to keep
doing the I could have canceled the tour
wouldn't have been a big deal but that
became healing for me in feeling like I
was serving that I was helping sitting
at the front of a room for four hours
with
immobilized neck brace on ice packs you
know on my neck two or three pillows
behind me and I couldn't move for four
hours but just talk
that became healing for me
and so
at least what's helped me for where I'm
at right now I'm totally open to to new
experiences and being changed and and
you know swaying my opinion before I'm
at right now
staying present
and doing
not just the work but doing activities
that you enjoy that you feel are in
service to others that you feel like
you're living your purpose that you feel
like you're having an impact think about
the things that you love doing where
where hours get lost I'm not talking
about like opening your phone and
scrolling through Instagram when you
realize that two hours have passed and
like how did I just waste all this time
not that but
in service of others and helping to see
I'm moving around right now I gotta move
I can't sit still
I don't like it when I get in creative
ideas I gotta move I play with my ring
you know they got the ring is all over
the place it's not just on my finger
this this gives me more creativity like
the motion creates more creativity for
me
and so if you find those things where
you love doing it's in service to others
is helping people time gets lost and you
feel it in your heart and your soul that
this is the right thing for you to be
doing for where you're at right now
that maybe that's you know maybe just
maybe that's the form of meditation that
you need the most
that
by staying present and helping others
and being in service maybe that's all
the healing that you need
maybe that is the present mind that you
need maybe that is the focus that you
need maybe that is the meditation that
you're already doing
and if that gives you some extra
perspective or a different view on
meditation than what you might hear
other places I hope that helps maybe
judge yourself a little bit less or
maybe lean into something that you
thought didn't exist because it
certainly played a huge impact on my
life and thank you for allowing me to
share the story with you people aren't
afraid of failing you're afraid of
failing in front of other people you'll
sing in the shower but you won't sing on
the street corner you'll record a video
but you'll never release it you'll be
your own biggest critic but you won't at
the same time also be your own biggest
fan that needs to change
starting today so my biggest fear is
disappointing people I'm terrified of
disappointing people the idea that you
would come to my thought Leadership
Academy and I would teach you how to win
on social media and get the ideas out of
your head and pay two thousand dollars
to do it the idea that that you would
come and be disappointed destroys me and
it's led to some positive things and
that I always over deliver I'm always
obsessed I'm always putting so much
value to that even if you only get 10 of
the value I'm giving you still more than
made the money that you invested into
any of the stuff that I'm doing but at
the same time it's still this fear and
so I want to attack the fear I teach
myself to attack the fear and I think
you should too an example was when I did
my tour
90 days 23 cities and I I did a paid
tour because I was afraid to do it and
this is supposed to be a free tourist it
was supposed to be coffee shop meetups
across the U.S low res super easy if one
person shows up great if nobody shows up
awesome if 100 people show up great
there's no risk right it's free you come
don't come whatever and my agent said
that's that's plain and small you got to
charge for the event and my first
reaction was oh my God I can't charge
this event right like
choking up because I'm afraid because
I'm afraid that that if I start charging
for it then I need to I need to bring so
much more value
and because that was the reason that I
had to go off and do it if there was a
strategic reason why I should do a free
event then that that's fine my next tour
I'm looking at for 2020 is going to be
free is going to be ideally fingers
crossed I get my book deal it's going to
be at bookstores with my new book launch
so I want to do 20 something cities east
coast uh Texas Mexico with my book
launch and it's it's free to come
hopefully you buy a book but it's you
know not required but it's free to come
out because it's going to be supporting
the book launch that's a strategic
reason why I should be free I didn't
have a good reason why the first one
shouldn't be free well the tour this
year shouldn't be free and so I had to
do it I had to step into the fear you
have to step into the fear and do it
because you need to attack the thing
that you're afraid of especially when
it's related to other people right I'm
not afraid of failing I'm afraid of
failing in front of other people right I
I can suck all day here in the office
but I don't want to suck in front of
somebody else I don't want to make
people feel like whether they're
spending 50 bucks to come and see me
that was on tour or 2 000 bucks to come
see me at my thought Leadership Academy
me here I don't want people to feel
disappointed and because I feel that way
I need to step into it and I try to
teach myself attack it attack it attack
it if there's no good strategic reason
why then I have to do it because
otherwise I'm playing small and even
just attacking it for the sake of
attacking it is good
even if it doesn't lead to a positive
result for your business it's good
because you're building strength because
you're pushing your comfort zone because
you're getting better because you're
growing that's worth something that's a
ton of value because if you can conquer
your fear of doing this one thing that
translates to every of your life if you
teach yourself to have more courage that
translates everywhere
so maybe you're afraid of if you're on a
cruise ship and they they bring up
couples and they do a game show you're
afraid of what might happen on that game
do it
how does that make you a better
entrepreneur makes you a thousand times
better as an entrepreneur because that's
the same fear that you face in your
business that fear of going on that game
show on the cruise ship that fear of
taking your phone and recording a video
in public on the street these fears that
seem like nothing they show up
everywhere in your life they show up
everywhere in your business
and so learning to tackle them
especially in low stakes
starts building the muscle who cares if
you fail on the street corner making a
video great go do it if that if that is
scaring you right now do it teach
yourself you do it you have courage you
do scary things
if you come on the other side you'll
come up with more strength and then
you'll start seeing things happen in
your business
you'll have more courage you'll have
more boldness you'll be more willing to
do things and then your business starts
taking off
you have to lose the fear of failing in
front of other people I'm going to give
you three ways on how to do it step
number one is embrace your bold ideas
I'm a big believer that when you have
these moments of boldness maybe it's
happening right now maybe you're feeling
bold right now watching the video
amazing you have these moments of
boldness we have moments of boldness
I don't think people are bold all day
long right and if you are then you have
moments of even greater boldness hear
these moments these spikes these hits
right you go to an event I look at
people coming to my thought Leadership
Academy they have these huge moments of
boldness right and then you fall back
down
and that's normal you're watching a
movie you get inspired you fall back
down you have a conversation you get
inspired you fall back down the
decisions that you make in the moments
of boldness I believe are the right ones
for you
those are the decisions you have to
follow through on and embrace and then
your head talks you down from them the
head brings you back down the plane
small
and so when you're feeling bold what
have you come up with I want to go do X
have to deal with doing you have to
start building momentum you have to
start committing with some other people
embrace the Bold ideas recognize that
those aren't the crazy ideas those crazy
ideas that come up with your affiliate
mold are not crazy those are actually
the best ones for you you're just buried
under a pile of garbage of limited
beliefs on top of you those are the
things you have to go chase down and
when it gets hard when it gets difficult
when you want to quit remind yourself
this idea came to me when I was feeling
bold I have to do it because I do both
things you teach yourself step number
two is expect to suck this is where it
gets super liberating expect to suck the
first time you do anything expect to
suck why do you expect to be great the
first time out what do you expect your
first video that you make to be great
it's not
it'll suck that's the best it should
suck right if you are
you are amazing like in your first video
then you should have started making
videos four years ago I believe that you
waited too long your first at anything
should be terrible doesn't mean that you
suck I think you're amazing you're a
genius you're Michael Jordan you're the
best of all time it's something
but Michael Jordan didn't didn't dunk
his first ball right he didn't he didn't
shoot and it went in right away right
you suck at the beginning that's normal
learning any skill kill you suck at the
beginning and it's really hard because
you know what looks good if you want to
be a basketball player you know what a
good basketball player looks like if you
want to be a YouTuber you know what a
good YouTube video looks like but then
you can't do it yet your first one sucks
and that's where most people quit
because they expect to be good they're
worried about looking bad in front of
them people they're not good the first
time out and so then they never go back
to it and this is what happens when when
people are are growing up you fail all
the time it's normal it's okay you fall
down awesome you get back up you keep
going and then we stop trying
as adults how often do you try new
things how often are you willing to risk
failure to risk losing to risk looking
like a fool
you don't want them so you're not trying
as much anymore and you ever find the
thing you could be Michael Jordan at you
never find it and you get stuck in some
life in some job that you hate forever
that's most people I don't want that to
be you you need to try more you need to
explore more you need to expect to suck
the first 18 times of doing something
you may suck amazing keep going the most
important thing is are you liking it do
you like the process successful people
love the process I love making videos I
like this process this fires me up I'm
just sitting here by myself in my office
talking to a camera I love it this is
great I love it for other people they
may hate it amazing don't do that go do
something else go go build little Teemo
toys right awesome whoever made this who
made this
designing California oh they didn't even
they didn't give them credit all right
design in California
right go make toys go do something go to
the thing that you love
expect to suck but if you love the
process of it you will get better
think about when you whatever you
learned in school most of it you forgot
but this thing that you remember the
stuff that you connected with that you
liked more so when you love something
you're going to just learn a lot faster
when you like something you're going to
get better a lot faster even if you suck
at the beginning you'll get better a lot
faster you have to find that thing and
step number three is tie yourself forth
to the effort not the result what I want
you to do is go home and then sleep and
think am I proud of my effort am I proud
of what I did today am I proud of the
effort that I put in today I want to be
proud of my effort today in making
videos when I'm trying my best maybe
it's not good enough maybe today sucks
awesome but I'm trying I'm proud of my
effort I'm proud of the attempt most
people tie their software to winning to
the results to the money to the gold
medal to the to the whatever right to
the YouTube to the plaques back there
you can't do that because if you tie
yourself Worth to winning
you're only going to do things that you
know you're gonna win at
and therefore you play small for life
if you value winning above everything
else
you'll only do the things that you know
you're going to win at and so you play
small for life you stop trying new
things because you're gonna fail at the
beginning right expect to suck you don't
expect to suck you expect to be great
and then you're not and so you stop
doing that thing you'll only take on
small projects but you you're capable of
way more your people doing something
much bigger
and so when you tie yourself forth to
the effort when you say I am proud of my
effort today
if you did that every day you're gonna
probably lose way more than most people
right you're going to be getting up and
losing almost every day and then you
have these big wins
but when you look back on this year of
losing you'll see holy cow how much have
I grown and you're actually winning way
more than most people way more than who
you used to be because you're part of
your effort if you get up every day and
you're part of your effort
your life will change your business will
change like every day for the next year
do something that makes you proud of
your effort in your business in your
relationship proud of your effort you
tried your very best today
your life will be dramatically different
but it's because you're so focused on
winning you're so focused on the results
but then you you play small because you
don't want to risk losing you don't want
to risk failing you want to risk looking
like an idiot
you have to
if you want the life that you're after
Michael Jordan missed more shots than
most people
you're going to fail at most things most
my videos suck and don't go anywhere
but get up try again be proud of your
effort every single day eighty percent
of our inner dialogue is negative and 95
of those thoughts are the same thoughts
that we had yesterday that's what Beth
Handel taught me she's garyvee's life
coach we had an awesome session together
and it really hit home imagine that 80
percent of the thoughts that you've got
eighty percent
are negative we are beating ourselves up
we are telling ourselves that we can't
do things it's not even our friends and
family people around us telling us that
we suck it's us it's ourselves we tell
ourselves we're not good enough we can't
do this we're not strong enough smart
enough we're from the wrong country we
look the wrong way you know we're too
young we're too old whatever it is 80 of
our thoughts are negative and then 95 of
those negative thoughts are the exact
same negative thoughts that we had
yesterday it's no wonder why we stay
small it's no wonder why we stay stuck
because we've created this reinforcing
Loop of negativity this is why I think
the world's biggest problem is lack of
belief I'm on a mission every day wake
up try to make content try to spread the
message to help people believe in
themselves more I think lack of belief
is the single biggest problem in the
world
and I also believe that everybody has
Michael jordan-level genius as something
like you are the greatest you're the
greatest in the world at something and
it's not what you went to school for and
it's not what your parents did for a
living probably it's something
completely different and you have to
have the courage to go off and Chase it
and find it and and do it because the
woman who solves cancer should have
already solved it by now but she never
believed in herself enough to go to
medical school and now she's a manager
and accounting firm which doesn't like
her life right I mean this is this is
where most of us are stuck most people
wake up and they drive their job that
that we don't like most people are stuck
and barely hanging on and do not like
their life and feel like they're not
contributing they're not they're not
making any kind of difference they're
not doing anything meaningful or
impactful at all in the world that's
most people like imagine waking up and
that's your daily reality that may be
you
or that may have been who you were and
you still describe it and trying to
improve and get better but if 80 of
those thoughts that come through your
head conscious or unconscious are
negative I think a lot of conscious
thoughts are negative too
not just the subconscious the conscious
thoughts are negative you telling
yourself that you can't do something and
you're not good enough and then 95 are
the same as yesterday that we've just
created this this Loop this negative
thinking Loop
so how do we break it how do we break
free how do we solve that problem well
that's that's the billion dollar
question and that's what I wake up
every day trying to fix and I can give
you a couple things that I've worked on
that I found helpful and hopefully helps
move the needle they don't have all the
answers but but some of these might help
the first one is to change your
environment the environment makes such a
huge difference for who you are and your
daily habits and what you believe about
yourself and the environment is not just
the people who are around you although
that definitely helps you know if you've
got negative friends or family around
you you want to eliminate them
completely or spend a lot less time with
them because it's really really really
hard to have a beautiful plant grow when
it's just you know toxic waste being
poured on top of them doable but really
really difficult and so changing that
can really help and
one of the best ways I found to do it is
content
it's content it's why I make so much
content for these channels that
hopefully
you wake up today and there's a piece of
content there waiting for you whether
it's me or showcasing somebody else
across all my channels or making
multiple pieces of content every single
day to try to hit it in the right way
maybe today's message with the right
voice is the one that makes a difference
for you and if you can shift
the amount of entertainment you're doing
or just shutting off the world some of
the content that you consume just helps
you shut off the world and Escape versus
educational content that helps you learn
improve get better and solve the problem
right entertainment is let's forget
about the problem and just laugh at
something else
education is let's learn to actually fix
the problem that is happening in our
life right I want to lean in on that a
lot more it doesn't mean that
entertainment doesn't exist in your life
it's not only education but if you can
shift the needle towards education to be
around the people who inspire you even
if you've never met them
it can really move the needle for your
your inner dialogue and your
self-confidence so the thing that saved
me in my first business in doing this
was modeling Bill Gates or Microsoft
when I I quit on my business partner I
struggled I didn't know you know I felt
worthless nothing was working I was
working every day and just no results in
in looking at Bill Gates's story that
that changed my life it saved my
business it allowed me to keep going
because now I had a little bit of hope
that Bill Gates could do it maybe I
could too and the more you surround
yourself with those people
the more you'll feel like you can do it
too so do an audit how many people in
your life the the actual humans that you
know and also just the people that you
subscribe to that you follow how many of
them make you feel better about yourself
and for too many people it's it's not
enough you know it's it's look at who
you follow on YouTube look at who you
subscribed to
um look at who you're connecting with on
Instagram you know if you're loading
your phone you're going through
Instagram or you're watching YouTube
videos how many times have you gone
through it and all of a sudden an hour
has gone by and you were mindlessly
watching videos or even worse made you
feel worse about yourself you ever felt
that you watch a video and then you feel
worse about yourself afterwards or
you're following somebody and it makes
you feel worse about yourself you have a
choice to unfollow those people this is
not Instagram's fault or YouTube's fault
you can take accountability here you
have a choice to unfollow those people
and then a choice to follow the people
who make you feel better about yourself
that's my aim with all these videos I
want to leave you with strategies but
also more belief in yourself at the end
of every video and if I do that I
awesome you want more belief in your
life come back you know another shot of
espresso tomorrow morning we're here and
if I don't do that cool thank you for
giving it a shot and and don't quit on
that go find somebody else who gives you
the motivation inspiration that you need
and so you can make a conscious choice
because it's so easy to stay stuck it's
so easy to stay small it's so easy to to
be the one that pours in other people
and not have anybody pour into us and
you need to make a conscious choice to
to raise your environment to change your
environment and it doesn't mean you have
to go move to a different country or
move to a fancier house or anything else
you start by just changing who you
associate with even at a mass scale
right
I've learned a lot from Steve Jobs I've
been inspired by Oprah Winfrey my
favorite entrepreneur of all time was AP
giannini who started Bank of America
these are people who I've never met
you know and and in the case of jobs in
Janine I never you know will meet
because they've passed
but I've been inspired by them and
they've made me better and they've
taught me and I've learned from them and
they've inspired me and I get courage
from them
because I've consumed their content
and you can do that too
it's just being intentional about it so
that when you raise your environment you
raise your life
the second thing is try not to do it
alone
it's really hard to go after
a goal to change your mindset to
accomplish big things when you're doing
it all by yourself you know
it this is why a lot of people quit
because you might have one one amazing
day or you watch The Right video you
have the right experience and it's like
that I wanna this is this is the life I
want you ever had that right like this
is the life that I want this is who I
want to be this is this is where I could
go you have a glimpse of a potential
future that you could be it's like I
want that and you actually feel in your
heart that you can be that you can
accomplish that right does that happen
to you and then what happens the next
day you wake up and it's kind of gone
and then the next day it's completely
gone and then you're back to your old
life and the limiting beliefs and the
habits and and you know you gain back
the 20 pounds and like how did I end up
back here I thought I fixed this right
has that ever happen to you
a lot of it is because you're doing it
alone
and this took me a long time to figure
out
as an introverted person as a shy person
as somebody who doesn't like asking for
help
um
as someone who's afraid of disappointing
people
being a part of a community is not
it just sounds super scary to me
we just did our seven day challenge for
built to serve and a bunch of people
join movement makers I had almost 100
people joined movement makers at the end
of it and it's people who want to be
thought leaders and want to be speakers
and authors and coaches and course
creators and membership creators and all
of the stuff there's a big impact that
spread your message and I was giving
people
a lot of uh
not just encouragement but respect like
the people who ended up joining I just
had incredible respect for
because I wouldn't have done it if I go
back to 19 year old Evan when I started
my first business I wouldn't have done
it I wouldn't have had the courage to do
it I wouldn't have joined the group we
had people sharing their videos like
tell us about your your who your why
your how is your this methodology from
the book but make a video you know
sharing your purpose and your biggest
pain of all time and some of these you
know kind of deep uh things that you
have to record and share and I mean it
was optional not everybody did it but in
doing that
for a lot of people it was their first
video that they've ever done
for a lot of people it's the first time
they've even shared their story to
anybody that they were sharing things in
the group that they hadn't told their
spouse
you know or their family or their best
friend and now they're making a video
in their car
sharing their story
and you see them become liberated you
see them you see them start super scared
and Afraid and unsure and fixing their
hair and you know apologizing for the
lighting not being good and them being
in the car and not knowing what they're
doing
to then just seeing the transformation
of somebody
going through the Cocoon you know being
a caterpillar and turn into a butterfly
and sharing their story for the first
time and I was in awe because I I
couldn't imagine me doing that at 19
when I started my first business
[Music]
I was too afraid to join a community I
was too afraid of being judged
I was too afraid of being not good
enough
and that kept me small
I kept my growth really slow
fortunately I kept going you know if
you've seen my my
chart on my website where I show how
much I've grown every year over year
over year over year where I've been took
five years to get the seven thousand
subscribers or something like that
and I just kept going and the one thing
that I've got was just tenacity and
drive and I will just keep going in the
face of adversity
but I made it just incredibly hard on
myself being alone not being open to
sharing with my friends what I was
struggling with and never joining the
community
so I think that can really help you you
know I think I think trying to go and
change your mindset and accomplish big
things that nobody around you has done
yet and there are some days that you
feel incredibly inspired and motivated
and Powerful like yeah I can do this but
you're probably not living there most of
the time
what if you did or what if you lived
kind of close to that most of the time
and point number one of raising your
environment can definitely help
but Point number two is just don't try
to do it alone
even if it's one person you don't have
to join Movie Makers you don't have to
join a group
but even just one person
one person who you can talk to you can
connect with
who you can you know share your stories
with not just complain to not not talk
about how hard everything is and just
have somebody to vent to but somebody
who supports you
if you had a group of people who
supported you
well you felt welcome we felt like you
weren't alone in this journey we felt
like people understood you
and we're actually genuinely cheering
you on to go you know become the person
that you want to be
Everything Changes
so raise your environment
get a community
and watch your impact happen I was in
New Mexico
and I was doing on Super Bowl Sunday my
workshop and it was the smallest group
on our tour and we're talking about
morning routines and there was a woman
there and I asked her what what's the
most important part of your morning
routine
she said prayer I said so you pray how
often you pray every day every day every
day you praise your praise perfect how
often do you feel
the prayer how often do you feel the
connection and how often are you just
saying the words
she said like half the time
great
other people might look to her and say
well look you do it every day even for
herself she might look in herself and
say great I did it every day as
Achievers we like to check the box right
you like to check the box I did it I did
it I did it I did it I did it I prayed I
watched the video I read the book I
brushed my teeth I whatever you have
your checklist and you did it right and
you feel great that you did it but if
you don't get the feeling
of courageousness and you just check the
box it doesn't count
so watching a video might be part of
your morning routine
great I'm you know if it's mine I'm
honored to be a part of your journey but
somebody else is amazing do that too
but if you know that watching a video is
the thing that helps make you feel alive
bold confident
you know that there are some days that
watching a video actually makes you feel
that way and other days where it doesn't
and you know that watching the same
video over and over and over and over
every day will lose its impact super
quick right day one you're motivated day
two already you've lost like 80 of the
motivation that you got from day one day
three it's basically over you run it for
a month forget it like you've already
memorized the words that the words don't
mean anything to you anymore
so you have to have some variety
and if you're watching the video while
you're doing something else
this is the achiever's curse you're
watching the video while you're brushing
your teeth while you're taking the dogs
out while you're cleaning the sink while
you're making the bed you're distracted
you're doing something else you're
trying to multitask right here's what
happened to the achievers you still get
to check the box to say that you watch
the video
but because you weren't present for the
video guess what happens there was no
retention there was no feeling you don't
feel ready to take on the day you don't
feel the boldness to courageousness and
therefore you don't go and have a great
day even though you checked off
everything on your morning routine
that's what makes a difference
so if you get to the end of your morning
routine and you don't feel bold powerful
courageous ready to go for the day
there's one of two things that you have
to do one is you audit your morning
routine you say What's missing
you know like does this still work for
you anymore what's missing do I need to
add something in do I need to add an
espresso video in during the morning do
I need to add reading do I need to add
working out do I need to add writing my
goals down like what do you need to do
to add and tweak and experiment and see
if it makes you feel better
or two
maybe you just need to do the routine
again but with more intention maybe you
did the whole routine while you were
distracted
maybe you did the whole routine while
you're thinking something else
so you don't get the feeling there's
nothing wrong with the routine the
routine is great
routine is perfect for you
but if you don't show up with intention
if you don't show up and be focused on
it you're not going to get the feeling
you could sit there and be in the chair
and think about going to classes going
to school you could sit there be in the
chair doesn't mean that you're going to
learn
you can sit there and watch your video
but if you brush your teeth and doing
eight other things
you're not going to get the feeling
this is the loving push forward that I
hope you accept
because everybody else is going to look
at you and see how much you're doing and
how perfect you are and how much
momentum you have and
how many things you're doing and they
look up to you in awe
and you're an inspiration to them and
you should be because you are doing
amazing things
and at the same time you know it's
nothing compared to what you could do
but the difference between where you are
right now where you want to go is
actually not that big
the difference is just minor tweaks
between where you are right now where
you want to go for most of you it's just
minor tweaks
this is one of those minor tweaks
that if you could just stay consistent
on having a morning routine
and then inside of that consistency
doing the thing that makes you feel bold
powerful Unstoppable alive ready to
start the day not expecting to be
amazing when you wake up but then doing
the thing that brings that out of you
every single day your life
will change you can change the negative
patterns that I run in your life
the patterns that you think are
impossible to break that have been with
you for life that will be with you for
the rest of your life you can break them
it starts with a decision and if you
don't want to still be in 20 years
living by that same negative pattern
that is holding you back
I think this video will help most of
what we do is subconscious most of what
we do is beneath the surface most of
what we do is
what we've been conditioned to do and
the patterns that we've seen and you
know if you're watching this you're
likely an adult and we've been running
the same pattern programming for a
number of years if not decades and
it can be really difficult to be able to
switch that pattern but I'm going to
give you a formula today that I think
will really help and one that I'm
applying myself as well in my life so
step one
is even just acknowledging that the
pattern exists and that you want to make
a change
what is to happen
what is the negative Loop that's in your
mind what is the thing that you don't
want to still be thinking
in the next year two years five years
ten years what is that thing one of the
things that I'm working on is moving to
a space of great things happen to me I
had a great video coaching session with
Beth hendel and my big aha moment that
came from there was
I believe in the plan
so whenever I am thinking of something I
make a plan and then I execute the plan
and I do the plan and I follow the plan
and when I don't believe in the plan
then I create a new plan then I believe
in that plan and that's the thing that
gets me going so I'm very plain
scheduled calendar oriented that gives
me my security that gives me my identity
and so as long as I have a plan easy
peasy let's go waking up we're making
videos because it's in the plan
but then what happens on the rare days
you know maybe once a month where
I don't believe in the plan anymore I
don't think the plan is good enough to
get to where I want to go
and I can't make a new plan I don't know
what the next plan should be what I have
done so that I don't get lost and
spiraled down into negative thinking
into uh maybe not depression but
anxiety and stress and overwhelm that I
don't know what to do next you ever been
faced with that like I don't know what
to do next
my plan has been my plan team using the
words
just to tell myself
great things happen to me this is what
I've done it's my coping mechanism the
the way out of the stress and the
anxiety and not knowing what to do next
is me telling myself great things happen
to me
and what Beth challenged me to do
and the big Insight that came from it
was living not in the identity of the
plan but living in the great things
happened to me so now I'm trying to
shift my identity from being the guy who
believes in the plan to being the guy
who believes that great things happen to
me that instead of using great things
happen to me just as a coping mechanism
on my worst days the once a month days
when I really don't believe that I'm I'm
getting closer to my goals or I'm never
going to hit them
and flipping that to being the default
mode that's that's really hard I've I've
was not born the plan guy it took me
decades I'm 42 coming up in May I'm 42
and it took me decades to become the
plan guy you know two decades to become
the planned guy
and now I'm I'm not
getting rid of the plan guy thank you
plan guy you got me here I appreciate
you you know Pat in the back I still
need you please stay with me on this
journey but I want to be the guy who
believes the great things are coming
because at the end of the day all your
great things all your great ideas all
your great breakthroughs usually don't
come as a result of the plan
it's maybe a byproduct of the plan but
not a direct result of the plan because
the plan only is something that you know
exists right now it's it's what I've
talked about making decisions with your
head versus your heart big decision with
your heart and song with the head the
head only understands the world that
currently exists with your heart can
create something brand new and so I want
to be I want to be in the brand new I
want to create something that hasn't
been done before and so the you can't
plan for something that hasn't been done
before and you need to have some faith
that great things will happen and so
that's a long way of me saying that I am
trying to become
the guy who believes that great things
happen to me as a default state
I believe that when I say that when I
create video and I say that on camera or
when I'm talking I believe that I
believe the great things come to me if I
keep going if I keep making if I keep
sharing if I leave with my heart if I
tap into what I feel is the right thing
to do even if it doesn't make sense I
believe that great things will happen
and I've seen enough of that happen over
my life and career that I believe it and
if you're not quite there yet
just look for some small wins that when
you have help when you have shared when
you have created from the heart you've
gotten some small wins and if you keep
going you can have
slightly bigger ones and medium-sized
ones and then large ones and then
gigantic wins if you just keep going so
how do I shift and we're working through
this in real time I'm not sharing a
story that is you know
20 years old like I sometimes might do
the foundation story so how do I shift
how do I shift from being
the plan guy to the great things will
happen to mikai I think it could be
useful
Mini case study for you if there's
something that you want to work on
that you want to improve at you're tired
of telling yourself a different story
and you want to shift it so here's what
I'm doing first stop is trigger words
right so if I say plan that's a trigger
word plan ooh plan here's my plan plan I
said it again not that it's bad right
for years it might be bad it might be it
might be a critical you're telling
yourself that you're stupid or that you
can't or it can't it could be another a
trigger word or hard it's another
trigger word the fact that you're not
going to do something because it's hard
that's a trigger word right so what are
the trigger words that you tell yourself
as to why you can't do something or that
keep you locked in your negative
patterns what are those trigger words
that anytime you catch it you say it you
feel it you tell somebody else it that
like oh there it is again I'm noticing
it you can tell the people in your life
your your family your friends your
spouse people on your team you can tell
them
hey if I ever say this word I want you
to I want you to call me out in that so
you can have people kind of support you
through this journey as well number two
is you try to design in a conscious way
applying it in your life consistently so
the next thing I did as soon as I got
off that coaching call with Beth was I
told Nina I told my wife and I said hey
great things happen to us I told her
what happened and great things happened
to us great things happened to us great
things happen to us and I honestly I
must say that at least 40 times a day
great things happen to me to talk to
myself or great things happen to us
if you want you can set it as a alarm in
your phone you could put it as a
background on your on your computer
screen you can put it as a sticky note
on the bathroom mirror or the door I
have a email that I sent myself that I
didn't delete out of my inbox so so I
always see it in my inbox every day when
I'm checking my email I check my email
once a day and it's always the last
email that I that I checked because it
never removed from my inbox and it says
this is your great things happen to your
reminder
reminder every time oh that's right
great things happen to me because that's
still not it's nowhere close to being my
default
but I'm working towards becoming that
person
so it's the decision to do it and then
with intention putting things into your
calendar so that it happens so again
maybe you're setting an alarm on your
phone maybe you're putting the picture
up on your wall uh you're telling your
friends and people around you and you're
finding a way to repeat it to repeat it
to repeat it to repeat it and I'm not
judging myself as to I need to get this
done next week
I just want to make a little bit of
progress every day Beth's team reached
out and wanted to do a round two of
coaching and I said I'm still I mean
thank you it's amazing I'm still working
on the last thing you know the great
things happen to me
shift in mindset is something that I'm
working through and
it's incredibly powerful and I don't
think I need any help for anything else
yet I'm still working through this thing
this week has been a really challenging
week for anina and myself as well we are
we ran our build to serve challenge
which which is crazy
um when we first did it the the idea
that was pitched to me was seven days 45
minutes to an hour each day and we ended
up going the seven days and you know
three to four hours each day which I
didn't budget for but it was amazing
helping thought leaders and speakers and
coaches and entrepreneurs authors
just the energy and the vibe and the
love was so amazing that it took up an
incredible amount of time at the same
time we just bought a a brand new house
which is super exciting and so selling
this place and so I had to move my up
you might notice it's a different
background than usual I'm not I guess I
could have done it in my car
um but I'm not in my usual Studio my
office because we have a makeshift
office while we get our place ready to
list today
so we're packing and moving and
switching all the artwork and all of
that stuff while running a challenge uh
yesterday I hit the side of a a curb
that had a rock
not a rock like a boulder and it
punctured my tire and not just like
giant hole in my tire uh so okay we have
to go and get the car fixed on top of
everything else which is why I can't
film in the in the car like I normally
do because I don't have a car right now
because it's being fixed because we I
blew out the tire and just issue over
issue over issue and
my niece was with us yesterday
and she made a comment to my wife Nina
about how calm we were through
everything like okay well the car tire
got blown out uh that's that completely
changes how we spend the rest of today
now instead of doing these errands and
taking people here and all of this stuff
on Nina's birthday by the way
it's like okay well here's what we need
to do now you know okay we gotta get
fixed we gotta figure out how to solve
these other problems and let's go and
she was my niece was blown away but how
we weren't arguing or fighting or
yelling or
uh super stressed just okay let's solve
the problem and keep moving around with
our day why because great things happen
to us
great things happen to us and that's you
know when something negative going on
even if it doesn't feel real
it'll be something that Nina and I will
laugh over great things happen to us oh
that happened okay great great thing you
know what great things happen to us
we will figure out a way through this
great things happen to us and in that
ongoing conditioning
the more that it's around us the more
that I say it I believe it a little bit
more and a little bit more and a little
bit more and a little bit more and I
guess you could call it affirmations I I
never really
connected to affirmations that much
because it felt
if I was saying something that I didn't
believe in that
that it wouldn't it wouldn't work for me
and because I already believed that it
wouldn't work for me then I've already
set myself up for feeling from the
beginning I think the key thing is if
you want to be able to change that
mindset you want to change the Habit
Loop you have to find something that you
actually on your best days believe
there's a kernel of Truth in there right
if you're 400 pounds you say I'm skinny
I'm skinny I'm skinny I think I think a
lot of
in your head you say well that's BS I'm
not skinny and and then you don't
there's no even kernel of truth to it so
then you never do the actions to help
you get there
where on your best days what do you
believe about yourself on your best days
how do you handle problems
so when I say great things happen to me
I believe it
I actually believe that that wasn't
something that was given to me that
wasn't something that somebody once told
me that wasn't somebody that a coach
told me that okay you have to use this
now as your Mantra I believe it on my
best days I believe it I believe it I
can I can tap into that and I believe it
there's a kernel of truth to it and I
want to make that kernel you know grow
into something much much much much much
bigger so homework would be to think
about
on your best days what do you believe
about yourself what what's the specific
language the specific words that you
would say to yourself to encourage
yourself or you're looking back and
you're proud of yourself on your best
days what do you believe about yourself
and then finding a way to make that a
daily part of your life
so that when the negative things come
you can tell yourself this as a reminder
and it starts to shift everything for
you the secret to getting everything
that you want out of life is to think
big and act small think big have a huge
Dream create a vision for yourself that
excites you that you want to make happen
and then act small don't let the big
dream be so big that it becomes so scary
and you never start find the smallest
possible way to just get started think
big act small otherwise your dreams will
stay exactly that I recently had a guy
pop into my Instagram live who was a
fitness Coach and he's he's building his
success up and doing one-on-one Training
Fitness and helping people get results
and he said Evan how do I go bigger how
do I build my brand how do I get people
to know me outside of just my my pocket
my community
well you have to create content you got
to be a thought leader you got to be an
expert I got to see you doing what
you're doing how often are you making
videos
said well I don't know making them once
a week okay great dude how often do you
go to the gym how often do you work out
how often do you care about your
nutrition
I said well every day like you have to
take this same approach to your business
to making content to being a thought
leader I said are you in shape and at
the time he's shirtless and then he said
yeah I'm in shape and he he pans down
and you see his abs and then back to his
face he's got the smile on his face like
I love it man
you've put that into your daily routine
you're working out and eating right as
part of your daily routine he said yeah
but it's so hard to to go off and make
videos every day
what are your clients saying to you
about working out and eating properly
that it's so hard dude it's the same
excuses you've already figured this out
in one area of your life the problem is
you're not being consistent in the other
areas that if you want to blow up and be
a thought leader and get a lot of
traction attention and Views you need to
get good at the thing you don't become
great at anything doing it once a week
if you believe that you have Michael
Jordan level Talent at something Michael
Jordan wasn't practicing basketball once
a week you just will never get great at
it you have all of this untapped
potential all of this abilities that go
off and make a huge impact but we never
see it because you're doing it once a
week you just will never get good at it
you'll never get good enough at the
thing if you're only doing it once a
week so he says what do I do great you
put into your routine
you already know how to do this you just
have done it for something else all of
you you've already been consistent on
something
now make this next business goal part of
your daily routine it's thinking big and
acting small most people think big and
have this big vision of where they could
go it's amazing I Believe in Your Vision
I love you I want to see you go off and
Crush that huge glow I think you can do
it
but then show me your calendar where you
take any action
because most people are spending too
much time just thinking thinking
thinking planning planning planning you
got to actually get going and doing it
daily consistent small action one video
from my friend who's running his gym now
one video is not going to do anything
one video one small Act is not gonna do
anything it's the accumulation of the
daily videos that are coming out the
daily content the daily improvements
that's where you start to build momentum
the biggest thing that's missing for
most of your ideas is momentum because
you're thinking big but you're not
acting small focus on one idea and make
it work focus on one business model
focus on one Revenue stream focus on one
social media Network and make it work so
many times we're focused on too many
things we're distracted and our
entrepreneur ADHD kicks in and as a
result nothing happens for all the
people who are telling you to have 13
different passive income streams because
if one goes away you still have all
these other 12 most of people who start
off doing that make zero money from all
of the passive income streams you're
making ten dollars a month four dollars
a month seven dollars a month where
instead if you could focus on one thing
and maximize it and make it amazing and
put your energy into it you will see
exponential results I look at social
media as an example and I just finished
this training where we did the seven day
build to serve challenge it was amazing
had so many awesome new thought leaders
coming to the program people have got a
big message want to serve and one of the
questions I kept getting asking is
how do I be on every social media
platform how do I be everywhere how do I
get started and just blow up everywhere
and it's like you don't right the answer
is don't don't don't try to do that
if you are the person right now who is
trying to be everywhere look at your
social media accounts
chances are you're sucking everywhere
chances are not not you suck as a human
just the results aren't there the
effort's not there the energy is not
there because you're so forcing yourself
to just get out there and create content
and be in all the platforms
that you also have a million other
things that you have to do and so as a
result you're you're creating
really mediocre content
content that people aren't interacting
with and if people don't like what
you're putting up it's not going to lead
to results for your business and so much
much much much much better it doesn't
mean that you can't be there you know
it doesn't mean that at some point you
can't be there that as you build your
brand and you get bigger and you hire a
team and you have more money that you
can start to do this but much better at
the beginning is to figure out
what is the one platform what is the one
Revenue stream what is the one business
model the one thing that if I focus on
that thing it's going to lead to results
so then I can scale
entrepreneurs have a hard time with this
because we want to do so many things we
have our add brain going on and
we don't want to just do one thing we
also feel like it
is limiting for what we want to do right
if you have a big Vision a big mission a
giant goal for what you want to
accomplish
doing just this one little piece of it
feels too small
the way that I would structure it and
think about it is this is just a
sequence
you still get to do everything
you still get to do it all
you just have to go in order you have to
create a sequence that the thing that
you need to focus on at the beginning of
your business whether it's your Revenue
stream whether it's social media success
whatever it is what you have to figure
out is how do I start to as soon as
possible get a sustainable business for
myself so that I can quit my job if you
have one so that I can bring income in
for myself my family so I can start to
afford to hire a team even if it's
part-time or one person so you can scale
up your company so that I can then go
off and do all the other things because
some of your ideas are are amazing and
huge and require more people and time
and effort and energy and some of the
ideas can get started a lot faster
and so if you want to go and accomplish
your big goal your big dream your big
mission then it's important to think
about the sequence of things that
instead of doing everything all at once
and as a result all of the results being
mediocre focus on the one thing that if
you push that lever you really maximize
that thing
you could start to make more money you
could start to have more impact you can
start to have more reach you can start
to see more success that then allows you
to bring on more people to help you
build and scale
for me we've got 37 people on the team
now
and
I can do so much more you know because
we got team than if it was just me by
myself doing everything and so in
building my mission I want to solve the
world's biggest problem right people
don't believe in themselves enough and
so in building that up I need people I
need help I need support I need team I
need I need a lot more than what I've
got right now
but and be able to build a business that
can bring in money then I can afford the
higher team that helps me accomplish a
lot more things and take on a lot more
projects but if I was at the very
beginning of what I was doing right now
I would not be doing most of the things
that I'm doing right now
I'd still be accomplishing and going
after the same mission
but I'd have to pick one thing to focus
on
I picked the one thing at the beginning
that I think I could make some money
doing this so that I can live I can I
can pay you know rent mortgage
I can pay my internet bills I could pay
for some food not not living you know
fancy life but just being able to live
and survive so I don't have to have a
job and then I would start thinking okay
how do I then scale this one thing that
I'm working on
to build up to the point where I can
remove myself or at least take some of
the pieces off so that I can hire a team
to help build and scale and grow if I
look back at my YouTube Journey here I
did everything at the beginning you know
I I uh I filmed it I researched it I
edited it I did all of it and it took a
crazy amount of time and I made a lot of
mistakes and I did a lot of stuff that I
probably shouldn't have done and
just by focusing on that thing and
making content and creating videos it
then allowed me to make a little bit of
money that then I could hire my first
part-time editor that then turned into a
full-time editor that turned into a
second editor and a research person that
turned into someone helping with the
thumbnails and the graphics and it
continues to build up and scale but
everything I was doing myself in a
mediocre way but getting it done
to then be able to scale out a team and
so most people are just stuck doing too
many things you start like look at what
you're doing on a day-to-day basis look
at your calendar you have a limited
amount of time right you have a limited
amount of time there's only so much you
can do in in a day in a week you have
other responsibilities maybe you have a
job maybe you have uh family kids health
that you have to look after you know
there's a certain amount of time that
you have that you can dedicate to this
thing that time needs to go into the
right efforts
and again it's great to have that big
mission and big gold and big dream but
if you have a limited amount of time
every day or every week
and you are
trying to create 13 passive income
streams with that limited amount of time
no one of the streams ever gets enough
energy enough effort Enough of Your Mind
space enough of your creativity Enough
of Your Love to ever become anything
and so you're diversifying way too
quickly you're diversifying way too soon
and apply that for anything that you're
working on apply that to your your
business and the and the opportunities
that you're chasing the Partnerships
that you're looking at the things that
you're saying yes to the social media
networks that you're trying to be on
do yourself a favor
don't try to be everywhere not yet
right just understand there's a sequence
to things and you can make it so much
easier for yourself to have more impact
to make more money to have a bigger
influence to be more proud of yourself
to start getting more success and more
results and more momentum so much easier
if you just sequence it out
so that you don't have to do everything
all at once you don't have to feel the
the handcuffs and the Restriction of
saying well I don't want to do this one
thing for the rest of my life this is
where it gets
you know entrepreneur Ade kicks in right
and we don't want to be locked in I
don't want to do the same thing forever
well you don't you won't do it forever
that's not the point the point is not to
do this one thing forever that if you
took these 10 opportunities in front of
you
you could do all 10. you could do all
10.
just not all 10 at the same time because
if you do all 10 at the same time none
of them are going to work out
and often it's a small opportunity that
can pay you more quickly
that can start to build the momentum for
you so if you have your list of your 10
opportunities in front of you 10 things
that you could do great look at what
order should I go in
so I can start making money and start
building momentum one last quick example
I look at a lot of thought leaders a lot
of people have a message a lot of people
want to be speakers and authors and
coaches and influencers and
they've got big goals and big Ambitions
for what they want to create
when I'm helping someone like that
usually the first option is coaching
the best thing to do at the beginning is
coaching so we're going to dive into one
specific business model right if you can
look at let's say be a speaker
uh getting brand deals as an influencer
writing a book and coaching if we had
those are four opportunities in front of
you right let's say so what did I say
being a speaker getting paid to speak
getting paid to do brand deals getting
paid to be an author and selling books
even selling courses your own materials
and training and Etc and coaching
those are those are you know four or
five different business models that you
can go through perfect
at the beginning which one is the best
what should you focus on
coaching
why
people don't like the idea of coaching
because you're trading your time for
money right I don't want to trade my
time for money okay
well what are you doing right now you
know you're at a job because if you're
at a job you're trading your time for
money
if you have unlimited time to figure
stuff out and you have you have a giant
bank account then you could do something
different but if you need to start to
make money to build this thing up then
yes you're trading your time for money
but it's a faster path to get you out of
your job and into your business full
time
where everything else takes a lot more
speaking takes an incredible amount of
time if you want to if you want to be a
paid speaker and and get paid enough
that it's actually meaningful
it takes a lot of time for you to get
good at the skill as well as for you to
build up momentum and a name in the
industry you have to do a lot of free
speaking gigs before you ever get paid
to do it so if you have a horizon of
years awesome but I'd rather you start
get paid immediately while we work on
the speaking career you want to be an
author and get paid to have a book cool
you can go and sell publish a book right
now if you wanted to you can get it out
you'll make you know you can sell it to
your friends and family your your
audience you'll make a a few bucks but
it's not going to be anything meaningful
to get a paid deal or to have a
significant even if you're going
self-publishing to make a lot of money
off your book you have to have a big
audience
to get the deal with a publisher they
want you to have at least a hundred
thousand followers that's like your
starting point to get in so is that
achievable of course but now we're
looking at years as a horizon as opposed
to like this has to happen right away so
you're not getting paid right now off of
your book so if you're sitting there
thinking right in the book creating a
great manuscript creating a great how-to
guide it's not going to be the thing
that helps get you any kind of money
anytime soon and I want you to get paid
because most people quit too soon on
their ideas or they're trying to do a
million different things at once right
if you're trying to create a course
same thing you have to build up enough
momentum you spend so much time making a
course creating the content filming
videos or writing instruction manuals or
creating the PDFs or whatever your
course structure is it takes so long to
make the course
and then you have to go and Market the
course and people don't know who you are
yet people you don't have a brand yet so
could it work absolutely will it pay you
more than coaching yes absolutely most
likely it's way more easy to leverage
that than coaching
but again the timeline is so long
and most people quit too soon on it
where if you were coaching you can you
can make money right away as long as you
have something that can actually help
people right if you're good at what you
do you know how to solve somebody's
problem you can make money as a coach
right away and yes you're trading your
time for money but it's better than
having a job and it also gets you closer
to your customers at the very beginning
I'm much I'm a much bigger fan of
selling a service and a product because
it gets you closer to your customers you
get to know their problems you know
their issues you know what exactly
they're struggling with and you can help
them solve it which allows you to create
a better book a better course a better
product because you've worked with
enough people through the problem
and so
most entrepreneurs fall into the
category I want to do all of it great I
want to be a speaker I want to be an
author I want to create my course I want
to create my book I want to be a coach I
want to do all of it awesome you have a
limited amount of time every week
to work on all five of those things at
the same time means there's very little
progress how if that's you and you've
been writing your book how long you've
been writing your book for
you're like when is it going to come out
what year
how many speaking gigs have you done in
the past three months
all right how much time has gone into
your course it's like we start and stop
and start and stop because we're
tackling so many different things
because you want to do it all and you
want to have income streams coming in
like crazy and there's nothing wrong
with that it's amazing but there's a
sequence
there's an order
that if you can as soon as possible
inside of your purpose
start to make money start to build
momentum start to be able to bring on
team to help you it's so much easier you
can go so much further you can go so
much faster you can have so much less
stress
you can have such a big impact
that you just need to focus
you just need to focus
it's all possible your big dreams are
possible
go in order figure out the sequence that
will start to get you paid
Focus this is where intentional learning
really makes a difference
I can't tell you the number of events
that I've done
whether it's virtual or in person where
there's always q a at some point
so if you're going to an event where
you're signing up for for a zoom call
and the person who you want to learn
from is on that call what most people do
is they become passive listeners
you're passively taking out your notepad
and you're taking notes you got your
phone and you're like taking notes on it
and like oh that's a good Insight that's
a good Insight but it's passive because
you are not
going in to the event with an outcome
your goal should be if you want to make
learning active if you want to actually
get the most from the experience and be
able to make the contacts and get your
questions answered you have to know what
the question is going to be
that you're going to ask right so here's
what you should do
first off whoever Your Heroes mentors
guides are
you want to follow them on all the
platforms so they can go live I just
before this I was live on Instagram
and we had a whole bunch of people
asking questions
follow if you want to talk to me follow
me on Instagram
join my Discord Evan carmichael.biz get
in there we're having great
conversations but the people who are
your Heroes follow them on the platforms
where they might go live look at where
they might be speaking at an upcoming
event
and then when you go and attend that
event have a plan for your learning so
that it's not just passively going
through the exercise and activities that
they gave you that's all a bonus
if you're gonna go to some conference
and there's an activity sheet or
workbook to go through great that's all
a bonus you need to know going in
what do I want to learn if I got a
chance to ask this person one question
what would that question be
what's the outcome that I want from this
most people don't do that
and you get caught up in the hype and
the energy and the motivation of ah it's
so amazing
but then you still didn't get the answer
that you could have had if you're just
more intentional
so you show up and then when they do the
questions like okay we're going to q a
boom you're the first one there
you're the first one there you're not
you're not you might be nervous your
heart might be pounding out of your
chest like crazy but you're the first
one there
you're standing by the microphone you're
ready to go you got your hand up before
they even go to q a in the zoom chat
right like you are ready to go with your
question the one that you want and
answer to
and then you're gonna ask the person hey
here's what I'm struggling with here's
what I'm working on
tell me why I suck
and then you get the feedback
if you apply that strategy
and go after the top five to ten people
in your industry in your Niche who are
doing the thing you can get access to
them
and if you intentionally show up with
that one question that you want an
answer to
and then you end it with tell me why I
suck
you'll get their brutal honest feedback
and get the advice you actually need to
grow with a push past failure is to keep
making progress part of the reasons why
you stick on failure and feeling so bad
about yourself and it's never going to
work out it's because there's nothing
new that you're working on that's
exciting that you're building towards
that you feel like you're making
progress on because when you're making
progress and you're moving forward you
can't feel like a failure and you don't
have time to think about the failures
that you've had
people ask me all the time hey what do
you do when one of your videos fail
like my videos fail all the time my
videos fail all the time all the time
and can I learn from them yes and can we
look at the data and the analytics and
show hey when this happened your video
tank yes and we do that and we learn
from it but I don't have time to sit
there and look at
all of just the failures and sit on it
because I've got more videos that I need
to make another video is coming out
tomorrow and another videos come out the
next day another videos come out the
next day and I don't know how many
videos we put out every day across all
of our channels but it's a lot of
content and I'm so focused on the next
thing that I'm less focused on the one
that was so learn from that awesome now
move forward and when you don't have
anything that you're moving forward
towards that's when it starts to really
hit hard
um and so that's
I think it's really important I think we
get too caught up on our first one and
it being amazing and nobody liking it
and so we're gonna stop and and even for
me my first video I figured how many
months it was between my first video of
all time and then my second video but
but it was a while before I kept going
because the first video didn't do as
well as I thought I I would do uh I
wasn't as good as I thought it was gonna
be I was way more nervous than I thought
it was going to be and I got no comments
right it's like my mom and my sister
commented on my video and I felt like a
failure so I stopped going
and the thing that saved me the most
over however many years of making videos
the decade plus has been you keep going
you keep making content you keep
creating you put it in your calendar and
you keep doing something to build
momentum towards a dream that you want
and so I think that's incredibly
valuable whether you're going through a
big failure or a mini failure I think it
helps when I look at big failures in my
life right so a video failing that's a
small failure right like this if this
video doesn't go and blow up it's a
small failure but big failures the two
biggest ones was one personal and one
business the business one is my in my
first company we I quit I'm a business
partner I just I felt like a loser was
not making money right making 300 bucks
a month having no results no traction I
just feel like a total failure and
nothing was working out and I told my
business partner that I quit and the
thing that got me through it was
eventually just realizing hey somebody
else has done this
I can model success and I looked at Bill
Gates and how he started Microsoft and I
learned from that and built my company
but it was that the progress that moving
forward instead of being stuck on how
everything sucks and I suck and I'm not
getting results and I'm just failing the
thing that got me the energy to keep
going was
feeling like this progress towards a new
idea or a new strategy to help me
accomplish my goals my biggest personal
failure was getting divorced over 10
years ago and that was that was really
rough you know it was a personal it felt
like a personal failure I mean it ended
up being the best thing for both of us
but at the time it felt like a huge
failure even just
saying that I you know am divorced
um
it just felt like a giant failure that I
suck as a human that that I couldn't
make this work and
that took a while to get through and
eventually the thing that
that helped me was
I I pulled up a dating app and I saw uh
options you know I was like oh you know
what okay this could maybe maybe this
could work or or that could work and
it's like
idea of progress
towards something instead of being stuck
in the past is the thing that started to
get me through to build some momentum
understand that if you're living in
Failure right now it's it's just the
past you're living in the past you're
you're frustrated with what what
happened and what you should have done
differently and could have done
differently and you wish you said this
or did that or acted a certain way
you're just constantly repeating the
past where to get out of the past to get
out of the failure now we need to think
present and future what are we working
towards what are we building towards
what are we creating and making and as
soon as you can shift from past to
present or future that starts to allow
your your brain to shift into forward
momentum and progress instead of living
in Failure so some of the steps that you
you can do that I think can help one
put activity into your calendar
so whatever you're working towards if it
didn't work out once awesome put in your
calendar to keep going
today's a Tuesday as I'm filming this
video Tuesday is my video day I'm I'm
making content on Tuesday
you know we're here and we're sitting in
the parking lot my my wife Nina is
running some errands doing shipping out
some built to serve books I believe
right now here at the shipping center
and I'm making content because it's in
my calendar if I didn't have content day
and it wasn't scheduled in I wouldn't be
making content I'd be doing something
else or I might be thinking about all
the past failures that I had in my
content but because it's a scheduled in
my calendar I'm making progress and
moving forward so whatever you want to
make progress and move forward towards
have chunks of time in your calendar
dedicated to doing it two have something
that inspires you it could be people it
could be remembering what impact you're
trying to have your big mission or your
vision you're trying to accomplish one
of the things that really helped me
early in my career is I made a
PowerPoint file of all the people who
came to my events my my seminars my
speaking gigs and
the message that they had for me they
wrote to me because I feel great the
next day after an event but then I would
I would lose the vibe and lose the
momentum that didn't feel like who cares
it doesn't matter anymore but I would I
would watch his PowerPoint file where I
put their quotes and how much of an
impact that was having on them and so it
reminded me of why I do what I do and
gave me more energy momentum to keep
moving forward that becomes critical
like what inspires you to want to move
forward maybe it's watching videos like
this maybe it's looking at testimonials
from the people who who you've helped
maybe it's remembering your big goal and
dream of what you're trying to
accomplish but what inspires you to want
to start building some momentum and then
three model success and find the people
who are doing the thing or have done the
thing that you're trying to do and learn
from them and study them and what that
does is it gives you
hope and strategies
when you are studying people who've done
the thing that you want to do it gives
you the hope that it's possible for you
too right because when you look at their
story they probably started with less
than what you have right now and in
studying them you can see oh if they
could do it maybe I can too it's just
that hope because you don't see anybody
in your family your friend's Circle
doing what you want to do and so it
feels impossible but when you're around
the people who are doing it even just by
reading their book or watching their
videos it gives you the hope that it's
possible and then two it gives you the
strategy of what you could be doing so
how do you go from where you are now to
where you want to be well if you're
modeling success and you see what they
did it gives you hope plus the strategy
to actually go off and execute so coming
back to the theme of failure what this
video is all about you're gonna have
tons of failure it's gonna happen like
if you are not failing it means you're
not taking a big enough shot right if
you're not failing you're just doing
things that you know how to do
therefore you're just in your comfort
zone therefore you just hate your life
right if if you're not if you have zero
failure happening in your life then
you're taking zero chances and you're
just doing what you know how to do and
you'll be bored and you won't like your
life so recognize that failure is a part
of the process and as soon as we can
move from past I suck as a human I made
all these mistakes too okay I'm moving
forward we're making progress we got a
big thing that we're chasing down when
you can move from failure to progress it
gives you the momentum it gives you the
hope it gives you the energy and ends up
giving you a lot better results as well
some businesses are just easier to build
on the scale than others some businesses
have a high growth market and some of
them are slow growth it doesn't mean
that you can't win but the opportunity
is going to be much different the upside
is going to be much different depending
on the market that you're going into
I'd love to say that a successful
entrepreneur is one who combines what
you love doing with the world as an
opportunity if you love doing it but
there's no opportunity or it's really
small then you've got a hobby it can be
really fulfilling hobby but it's when
you love doing it and there's a big
opportunity that's when you start to win
now if there's a big opportunity you
don't love doing it you're not going to
win either you can build an okay
business if there's a big opportunity
but you don't like doing it but only for
so long because then you're gonna quit
you're gonna hate your life because
you're waking up every day and doing
work that you don't like doing and
you're gonna quit this is where a lot of
entrepreneurs struggle they do one of
those two things they try to start a
business just around their hobby they're
what they're passionate about but
there's no Market opportunity they don't
know how to tie it into real demand so
they never build a business just a hobby
on the weekends any events or
they're just chasing the hot opportunity
and they don't care about the business
and so either way you're going to lose
in both those scenarios you win by doing
the work that you love
that has a big opportunity upside to you
as well I want to share two quick
examples uh that happened to me in the
past week that I think could be really
relevant and valuable one was that a
dear friend of mine asked me what social
media platforms am I focusing on and
we're talking about Instagram because he
he wants to go more hardcore and
Instagram want to know what I was doing
on Instagram and I said you know what
right now I'm not doing much on
Instagram you know I'm not spending a
lot of my effort my time my energy on
Instagram I love serving I love helping
I love getting the message out there I
want to do it in a way that has the
biggest potential or impact and reach in
the projects I'm working on so he said
well where are you spending your effort
and energy well YouTube was still number
one YouTube is number one because
YouTube is still the best place to get
your message across
it has been for the past couple years
and it's only getting bigger more people
are going to YouTube for content for
Education it's only getting bigger so
YouTube is still number one but then
after YouTube where am I spending most
of my time
Twitter
and Discord
Discord I think is the best place to be
for community and Twitter
it's surprising how how much Twitter has
picked up Twitter was one of the first
social networks I was on and I I not
left it but kind of ignored it for years
and now it's back it's back baby
so I'm spending a lot of my time on
Twitter and Discord and of course
YouTube and why well because that's
where people are that's where the impact
is that's where you get your message out
and so I don't care about the platform I
care about reaching people so you could
spend all day long working on on
Instagram or you could have spent all
day long still if you were working on
MySpace creating your account does
mystery still exist I don't even know
it's just not a big opportunity
and so yeah again what do I care about I
care about helping entrepreneurs I care
about getting a message out there so
then it becomes using your head okay
where's the opportunity YouTube Discord
Twitter PS if you want to join my
Discord server it's free I'm there every
day Evan carmichael.biz come check us
out
second quick example was I'm talking to
a successful entrepreneur who wants to
move from his
big business that he's built tens of
millions of dollars in Revenue to
starting a business to help other
entrepreneurs get their companies going
and he's having a hard time getting this
thing off the ground and is having a
hard time monetizing it
[Music]
and he's having a hard time getting
people to pay him for things
and I said well the immediate
opportunity you know if you have a long
Horizon great you'll you'll eventually
win because your brain will play out
you'll get better at them at the game
Etc but
the best thing you can do right now if
you want to monetize it is coach people
who are
inside of your industry that you have
domain expertise because what he's
coming out doing is just helping people
with personal development coming in
helping them believe in themselves
helping them overcome their living
beliefs you know uh helping them
fix their mindset get their schedule
right all that stuff but then if they're
off building their own business
he's only adding one little piece now
imagine if you could add the tactical
information and the contacts as well as
the mindset and the motivation so
there's two entrepreneurs three
entrepreneurs that I invested into
recently Drew
Jeremy and Bo and these three guys
some of them had no experience I think
Jeremy had it was a stock boy at a
grocery store
you made six figures Revenue 18 months
later why well because yes I'm giving
him the belief in the mindset and the
motivation but I can also give him
contacts I can also make introductions
for him I can also give him information
about the industry to know
what he's doing right and what he's
doing wrong and so when I'm looking at
making an investment into an
entrepreneur I want to be able to help
them Beyond just believe because I can
get believed to anybody but who I want
to give believe to have the highest
impact for Success it's going to be
people who I can give context to Jeremy
does YouTube Consulting there's people
who contact me all the time for you to
Consulting I don't want to do it
I don't want to be in that business so I
can give it to Jeremy perfect but if you
were a you know I don't know you were an
arborist can you see the trees I guess
not it's kind of blurry if you're an
arborist I could help you believe in
yourself I can give you some business
model ideas but I can't make contacts or
introductions for you
and so you have to be smart about the
opportunities you take on
it has to be something that you
deeply deeply deeply care about
and then inside that find the
opportunity
because the market is moving and the
market hopefully is getting bigger and
if you're inside a growing market and
you love what you're doing that's a slam
dunk that's a home run for you so
what's the methodology now to help
figure that out well one you have to
start with what do you naturally just
love doing what do you love doing what
can you wake up and get what do you what
are you getting lost in where are you
spending your time what are you
daydreaming about don't not about the
result not about the cars and the yachts
and the whatever right not that that
that's a result that what do you get
lost in the process of doing what
industry do you actually care about
where are you spending your time where
are you researching what doesn't feel
like work for you right so that's Step
One is is connecting to something that
you're actually passionate about not
just trying to make money right make
money is important but it's not step
number one
figure out that idea next is okay how do
we turn that into a market opportunity
where is the business actually growing
that we can connect our our talents and
our passions to so if you love send if
you love sharing a message like my first
example great now be strategic about the
platform that you're gonna pick
it used to be Instagram now it's YouTube
Twitter and Discord
if you love coaching people and
Consulting and investing in people great
connected to where you actually have
domain expertise and can make
introductions for people and take a
piece of their business as opposed to
just charging for the hour or just
helping people with mindset and not
actually introductions and tactics right
so you love the opportunity it makes you
come alive thinking about it and
there's actually something for you to
grow
right logically strategically is a way
for you to make money doing it when you
can combine those two things you have a
much much much much much much higher
degree of success great ideas flow
through you teach yourself train
yourself that great ideas are flowing
through you that the idea that you just
came up with that you've been thinking
of that doesn't make any sense is great
is amazing and is right for you because
quite often the ideas that come to you
don't make sense
are not practical someone like you
shouldn't do it
and whenever you're heading your heart
are misaligned
whenever your heart wants to do
something but your head tells you that
you can't do it
if you listen to your head you'll stay
small if you listen to the Practical
reasons why you can't do it then guess
what you won't do it you'll stay stuck
you'll stay small you'll stay crushed
for life knowing that you're capable of
more but never going after it so trust
that great things flow through you trust
that this thing that just came into your
mind if you're feeling bold ambitious
confidence in service that it's the
right thing for you and you need to go
and Chase it down when you are
accountable to other people you are more
likely to follow through whether it's in
entrepreneurship whether it's in
personal development whether it's
working out or working on yourself when
you are feeling like somebody else is
counting on you besides you you're way
more likely to follow through think
about going to the gym right you may not
like going to the gym
you may find reasons to put off going to
gym maybe it's early morning maybe
you're tired you didn't sleep well last
night your muscle still hurt from
yesterday all sorts of reasons and
excuses to come up with but if you know
that somebody else is going to be there
your friend is going to be there waiting
for you
you're way more likely to follow through
because now it's not just about you I
created a challenge inside my Movie
Makers program and movement makers is a
program I created to help thought
leaders experts who want to build up
their following and want to get their
message out to the world you got a big
message in here let's go to the world
and you train with me but you also get
to connect with each other and I was
frustrated that people were not making
enough content you've got such a big
message such a big potential voice your
story matters and people were not making
enough content and everybody was living
not everybody but a good chunk of people
were living inside the typical reasons
we all come up with right too busy I
don't know what gear to use I I don't
like how I look on camera my videos suck
over and over and over you know the same
reasons and so I decided to do something
a couple months ago that was different I
said you know what we are going to do a
challenge because the thing that's
missing is momentum
you guys have the heart and the soul and
the care just like
if you ever meet anybody in Movie Makers
it's just good people
um some of the nicest friendliest most
caring most giving people that I've ever
met you've got everything
you're just missing momentum
just not putting that up there because
there's there's too many there's too
much blockage in your head
you need momentum
and so out of that frustration I came up
with the momentum Challenge and my goal
with the momentum challenge was
for them to make content but not just
make content actually
create the content in a way that can
generate business for them so
the challenge was structured in five
pieces of the content one was a solo
video and the theme was momentum so you
have to make a solo video on momentum
two is three collaboration videos with
other people in movement makers so you
need to do an interview with somebody
and collaborate on the theme of momentum
and then the third thing was to do a
lead magnet on momentum so lead magnet
basically implies that you create a PDF
or you create a unlisted video that you
can share in return for people giving
you their email address so they email
you you get you give them the PDF and
now they're on your email list and you
can use that to continue to build a
relationship and ultimately work with
them hopefully in some capacity right
where you're serving caring and making
money in the process too
so that's a challenge
and whoever's in
you have the whole month to do it
and at the end of the month whoever
completes the challenge
we're going to do a clubhouse live all
together and celebrate
I didn't know how it would go
you know like I hope I hope people would
take me up on it but it's easy to have a
lot of excitement at the beginning right
every have you ever been excited by
something at the beginning and then
pretty quickly in you fall off the
tracks right has that ever happened to
you we're talking about a month here
it's not just make one video today it's
you gotta stay consistent for a month
you gotta make five pieces of content in
a month and for a lot of people
didn't know how to do collaborations and
never done an interview with somebody
else for a lot of people that didn't
know what a lead magnet was or how to
make one or how to save a PDF or how to
set up a landing page how to do all the
tech behind the scenes right and those
are the excuses that they were
holding on to for why they couldn't win
in their own business but now it's being
forced now you have to do it and I
didn't know how well it would work out
and
fortunately it went insanely well
people had some of the best conversation
of their lives people finally got the
tech side of their business figured out
with landing pages and Lead magnets
people started forming alliances and
Partnerships and cooperations and joint
ventures with each other that I'd never
even anticipated or seen
why because they were committing to each
other
because now it wasn't just about doing
it for themselves it was about doing it
with somebody
and here's what's important it's not
just doing it by yourself or for
somebody
it's doing it with somebody that makes a
big difference because if you're
watching this channel you're probably
heart driven entrepreneur right that's
why I love you it's why you're here
you're a heart-driven entrepreneur you
want to serve you want to make money you
want to have an impact right it's not
just about the dollars but also putting
something positive out into the world
that you're proud of whether it's making
content like this or products or
Services you want to serve you are built
to serve it's why you're here and I love
that
and so you can connect to the mission
and the service because you're doing it
for somebody right you're doing it for
your audience you're doing it for your
customers you're doing it for the people
who are going to consume what you're
creating
that's very different though than doing
it with somebody because most
entrepreneurs and and this is a good gut
check or look in the mirror for yourself
most entrepreneurs are doing it by
themselves even if you have a team you
still feel like you're doing it by
yourself there's nobody who actually
gets what you do does that sound
familiar
do you feel like you're kind of alone on
this people who support you or might cue
you on but they're not in the same boat
they're not trying to do what you do
they don't know how to help besides
giving some words of encouragement
do you feel like you're doing it by
yourself and man is it hard to do
something that's hard when you're by
yourself and that's where you need the
mental toughness and a discipline and
the scheduling and the calendar and the
and you do hard things
and one of the best hacks to make sure
you actually follow through is you have
some accountability
and not just somebody to just to hold
your feet to the fire to say hey you
know what are you doing you know you
don't need a boss
what you need to feel like you're doing
this with people
are you doing your thing but with others
and I think that's where the movement
makers challenge just really played out
super well is that now all of a sudden
people are booking collaborations with
each other and they know what to talk
about where before they wouldn't they
wouldn't book an interview because they
didn't know what questions to ask
people are now helping each other with
their landing pages and Lead magnets
where in the past they would tell
themselves I don't know the tech I'm too
confused I need to hire somebody but I
have no money to hire somebody and now
all of a sudden they're getting it done
now it's happening we're months or a
year might have gone by and they still
hadn't done it now all of a sudden
there's momentum happening
why because they committed to somebody
else and because they committed to the
group
that they want to complete this thing
and then the celebration when we did our
our clubhouse at the end of the month
the stories and the emotion was just so
amazing it became movement makers
started as me sharing a message I'm
going to teach you how to XYZ and it
became so much more about the family and
the community and the connection that
really people are following through not
just because of the ideas that I'm
giving them but because they have a
group of people that they're doing this
thing with
so find your own group
you know or find one person I have a
something I remind myself of constantly
that I like to collect good people
I want to find good people I want to be
around good people I want to be around
the people who fill me up who make me
feel like I'm worthy I can do great
things make me energized I leave them
feeling better about myself than than
when I came in I want to be around those
people and when I find somebody like
that I wanted I want to fight to find
more time with them
and as an introverted Thai person that
can be really difficult and awkward and
I'm still afraid to ask for help and I
probably still don't do that enough
somebody I there was a speaker who I
spoke at his event and uh he's like how
can I help you I was like I don't know
I'm here to serve you know I wanted to
help no problem you know but he wrote
back said no I I owe you like how can I
help you and and it's still something
I'm working on and doing a better job
and asking for help because I'll default
to him
find the solution myself don't want to
don't want to burden people you know
it's the story that is in my head that I
need to fix but when you can find people
to do something with when you are on
your path and you feel alone and you're
struggling and the motivation isn't
there but then you know that somebody
else is on the same Journey with you
you're so much more likely to follow
through
and so I encourage you not to do this
alone not to live life alone not to run
your business alone that you'll have a
greater degree of Joy Of Happiness of
impact of service of momentum of of
progress of results
when you have people
even one person
who you feel like you're doing this with
so don't
try to be the hero all the time and feel
like you have to do everything yourself
don't think well I'm doing this for
people and that that's enough
make it a goal
of yours
that in the next 30 days you're gonna
find somebody who's gonna help hold you
a little bit accountable and you're
gonna hold them accountable too
you're giving just as much as you're
taking
and together you're going to create
something amazing it's it's a true
scenario where one plus one equals 14.
you plus them equals tremendous growth
for both of you
you don't have to do this alone
get somebody to help you stay
accountable catching that pattern like
oh it happened again again again I
wanted to go and do this and I didn't do
it again I had this opportunity to talk
to somebody and I played small again I
had this chance and I didn't do it and
you're gonna catch it
a day later a couple days later and
reflect back on it and realize okay I
should have done it next time I'm gonna
try to have more awareness
step one is just the awareness game
because it's the problem is it's it's so
autopilot we play small by default
especially we've been doing it for
decades you play small by default so
it's so ingrained so natural so
autopilot that we have to slowly shift
out of autopilot Zone eventually what's
going to happen is you're gonna catch it
in less than a day you're gonna catch it
a couple hours later they're gonna catch
it an hour later they're gonna catch it
10 minutes later they're gonna catch it
five minutes later and then step number
two is you're gonna get to this magical
moment you're gonna get to this magical
moment where it's about to happen you've
caught it you've caught your small
thinking you've caught your scared
thinking you've caught your excuses
thinking
in the actual moment that it's happening
this is a magical spot right now because
you're actually calling yourself out on
your own BS right now and what you need
to do is get enough courage to actually
take the action to Pivot courses to
instead of doing what you historically
normally would do on autopilot now we're
going to take the other action the
action where you're proud of yourself
the action that you don't want to live
when you regret
that version of you showing up doesn't
order to things it's a sequence to
things part of the problem with a lot of
entrepreneurs is they're just not doing
the things in the right order
you're trying to tackle that big mission
from the start
doing all 30 things at the same time
and not making any money and not making
any momentum not making any progress and
ultimately not having the impact that
you want to have
so out of your 30 ideas all inside your
mission amazing which one is actually
going to start getting you paid
because when you can start making money
everything becomes better everything
becomes easier you can quit your job you
can pay your bills you can hire a team
you can have a bigger impact right if
you had a team of 10 people versus you
doing things part-time on the weekends
and evenings
you're just gonna have a much bigger
impact if you have you working full-time
in it and a team around you how do you
get there what's the one idea of the 30.
the number one way to deal with negative
people in your life is through empathy
it's empathy it's not it's not hating
them back it's not spreading negativity
it's not reminding yourself that you're
better than them it's it's empathy and
it's not even just feeling bad for them
it's actually connecting to them
let me let me explain
I default to assuming that people are
good this is a wild idea people are good
humans are good I've done the who
exercise the year one word exercise
helping people find the most important
core value with so many people and it's
always something positive
I believe that
99.999999999 of people are good there's
a tiny tiny tiny percentage of people
who enjoy killing people and maybe have
you know a few screws loose up here but
for the most part we're good everybody
has dreams everybody has Ambitions
everybody wants to serve everybody wants
to be in a better place than where they
are right now
the problem is
a lot of people are afraid a lot of
people are in pain a lot of people are
struggling a lot of people are suffering
a lot of people have tried they took
their shot and and it didn't work out
and because they're so in pain now they
don't want other people around them to
have success either
because if they took a shot and it
didn't work out
it's they don't want to own it that it's
on them but if you then go off and have
success you start achieving your goals
what does that say about them
right it's not that the world is rigged
against him it's that they actually suck
and they don't want to admit that and
they don't want to own up to that and so
they're living in pain
and so they take it out and other people
they take it out on you they take it out
on me they take it out on on the world
they take it out on people right that's
what that's what people do when they're
in a lot of pain think about you think
about your experiences your life think
about when you've been in a lot of pain
when you've struggled really think about
this the last time that you were
struggling in a lot of pain did you then
show up as your best self in all
situations
did you maybe lose your cool on somebody
did you maybe insult somebody did you
maybe say something that you're not
proud of that you later would regret has
it has that ever happened to you so that
you're a bad person it's not that you're
a toxic person it's not that you're a
hater
you were just in a lot of pain and so
the people who are throwing shade at you
are in a lot of pain they're struggling
and just recognizing that just trying to
put yourself in their shoes and look at
their life and if you know them you can
actually look at their life and if you
don't know them you can assume things
about their life if somebody's coming to
leaving a negative comment on your
YouTube video the fact that that is the
highlight of their day speaks volumes
about them right if the best part of
your day is going to somebody's YouTube
channel leaving some nasty comment that
gets you feeling good
you're in a lot of just imagine the pain
that that person's in mention what their
life is like right now
and it's a bit of a mental exercise
because at the beginning the natural
reaction is to be defensive like well no
I'm not this and how could you call me
that
and we want the people around to support
us and cheer us on and tell us that
we're doing the right thing so the
natural
defense mechanism kicks in where we say
no I'm that's not that's not right but
if you take a breather you can take a
step back and you can just
try to have empathy try to put yourself
in their shoes try to see that they're
in a lot of pain what it does is removes
The Sting from the words it removes the
Venom from the words it doesn't get you
to react as emotionally it allows you to
show up more as your best self
it's it's one of the most valuable
things you can start to practice this is
one of the things that prevents people
from creating content from posting
videos from sharing their thoughts from
you've got a big mission a message your
story can change people's lives you your
story your story can change people's
lives it will change people's lives and
we're afraid to do it because of how
people that we don't know or people that
we do know will judge us
we're afraid that we're gonna get
negative comments and that's the reason
why you're not putting your message out
there we have to learn you have to learn
to stop getting in your own way and to
start sharing to start releasing to
start living your life the life that you
want not somebody else's version of it
I'm going to substitute mission for
purpose your purpose is what you are
here for your purposes what do you wake
up excited to do your purpose is what's
the impact that you want to have on the
world what do you want to be known for
what do you want to create
your purpose is the thing that keeps you
going when when you want to quit when
you want to give up when you feel like
it's not happening fast enough when your
goals aren't enough to keep you going
what is the thing that keeps you going
it's your purpose
to feel like what you are doing today
matters is Meaningful is going to have
an impact and
people have asked me somebody asked me
yesterday is doing IG live and somebody
asked me how do you
how do you keep going you're one of the
most consistent people I've ever seen in
my life
uh how do you keep going how do you keep
making videos well I feel like it
matters I'm living my purpose I don't
think what I'm doing is that unique that
special I think everybody can do it
it's it's within reach for everybody to
do it the problem is most people are
just chasing opportunity
and just trying to make a quick buck and
making money is very important it is
very important it's just not number one
number one is your purpose
if you woke up and felt like today
mattered that it was gonna mean
something to somebody you're gonna show
up in a totally different way you're
going to show up with more energy it's
going to be easier to say yes
I was making videos for years with
getting almost no views zero comments
why because I felt like what I was doing
mattered that if a hundred people saw my
video that's 100 people that's on my
video or if you're just chasing the end
goal if you're just chasing oh I need to
have a million subscribers so I need to
have X in my bank account
you stop you will quit because it gets
too hard
where if you actually felt like I'm
gonna show up today and I'm gonna do
something that matters and it's going to
change at least one person's life there
are some days when you feel like you can
change the world right there are some
days when you feel like I can do
anything I could change the world I'm
going to X right there are some days
when you actually feel that and it's
amazing and there are some days where
that feels too big and too scary and
your purpose feels too overwhelming and
and it should be it should be
aspirational it should be beyond your
reach it should not be something that
just gets solved in your lifetime it's
something that you want to swim forever
to climb forever to keep chasing down so
there are some days where it feels too
big and on those days don't stress about
it being too big worry about hey I'm
just gonna help one person for me when
I'm stressing out about making content
making videos
speaking on stage whatever else I'm
doing some days like I'm gonna change
the world today and other days is
I hope I can reach a few people with the
video
this is a Tuesday for me I record videos
on Tuesday every Tuesday I make content
into my calendar and it's always the
most
stressful day for me
in my week because I always want to make
the best that I can I want I want
today's video to be the best that I can
with what I've got
because I want to have an impact I want
I want hopefully this video and the way
that I say it and just hope that this is
the one that finally resonates with at
least one person The Hope isn't I need
this video to go get a million views or
I'm a failure the hope is
that for you maybe for you maybe you're
the one today
that the way that I say it
hits you in the right spot that pushes
you towards some kind of action to take
that thing that's been sitting inside
your heart that you've been sitting on
for a long time that you know you'll
want to do and get the permission get
the courage to actually go off and do
the thing
that's what purpose does for you
purpose demands that you grow into a
better version of yourself because you
won't do it just for yourself
if your goals are just purely selfish if
it's just to have money in your bank
account or buy a certain car or whatever
the goals just for yourself will not
sustain you through the long stretches
of bad times that it takes to go off and
actually build something meaningful the
thing that sustains you is feeling like
this is of Greater
service to other people than just me
Okay so
everybody has a purpose the purpose is
the thing that gets you going the
purpose is the thing that keeps you
motivated the person the purpose is the
thing that makes you want to do
something today how do you find it Well
finding it doesn't have to be a
difficult process I wrote about it in
built to serve I believe humans are
built to serve and finding your purpose
comes from your I call it your why and
your why comes in your pain your purpose
comes from your pain your purpose
it's not something that changes next
year or the year after or the year after
it's not it's not what's my purpose for
this year
that's a decent enough conversation even
figuring that out if you wanted to go
down that path what's my purpose for the
year it's already more self-awareness
than what 99 of the world has but that's
still not your life's purpose your
purpose is the thing that at 120 years
old you're still obsessed about my
purpose isn't to grow my YouTube channel
I don't know if I'll be doing YouTube at
120 years old that's too far away for me
to think about my purpose is to try to
solve the world's biggest problem which
is that people don't believe in
themselves enough and when I'm 120 years
old that will still be there and I will
still be doing whatever the the modern
technology is right if it's YouTube
amazing if it's VR something totally
different I'll be doing that because I
want to solve that problem
that's what I wake up and really trying
to do why well because the purpose comes
from my pain because what I struggle the
most with
me oh Nina brought some coffee we love
you Nina
look at the steam look at the steam I
bought this guy coffee and you bought
the homeless guy coffee he says his
birthday it's his birthday look at Nina
so special
spreading her purpose love it my purpose
came from my pain I struggled so much as
an entrepreneur
I felt the lowest
as a human I felt worthless I quit on my
business partner I thought it was never
going to work out I I just felt
incredible pain I felt lonely isolated
worthless
and I did quit on my business partner
and then luckily I came back the next
day and just decided I can't quit on
this yet and I'm still making all of
this content all of my material how many
years later let's see that was that was
when I was 19 20. I'm 41 now so 20 plus
years later still helping still making
content still going and it's going to be
another 80 years of doing this because
there are so many people millions of
people who are 19 year old Evan right
now struggling with the same thing
whatever you struggled with
think about in your life that the
deepest
most traumatic experience where you felt
worthless as a human being the most
painful emotionally moment that you had
to go through
and you barely made it you know you
didn't you didn't Triumph your way
through it you struggled but you made it
and now you're here and you're still not
where you want to be but you're way
further ahead than you used to be right
you right now could go back to you from
10 years ago five years ago seven years
ago and give some great advice
that's your purpose
to know that there are millions of
people right now who are currently the
person you used to be and they may not
make it through
they may not make it through like you
did you had the strength you had the
courage you had the strategies you found
the way and you made it through and they
may not and they need you they need your
voice they need your hope they need your
inspiration they need your message they
need you in a way that they won't listen
to me they won't listen to Tom bilyu or
Tony Robbins they won't listen because
they don't connect to us but they will
connect to you because you are like them
so it doesn't have to take you years to
figure out your purpose you don't have
to go to a retreat you don't have to go
meditate on a mountain you don't have to
hire a fancy business coach you don't
you have to you don't have to do any of
that you already know it
you go back to the most painful moment
in your life
where you felt worthless as a human
being
and then just deeply connect to that and
feel and know that there are many people
out there right now
who are that right now
and they have no hope and no guidance
and no leadership and no wisdom and they
feel stuck and they they feel alone they
feel afraid they feel ashamed they're
not reaching out they're not asking for
help and they're going and they're
searching they're searching they're
going to YouTube they're going to
YouTube they're going to YouTube they're
going to YouTube how many times I say
that they're going to Google they're
going to Twitter they're going to
Facebook they're they're searching
they're searching for help for answers
could be the one that shows up
and if you actually felt that
[Music]
that on some days you could change the
world and on some days
you could change one person's life if
you actually felt that
you'll show up completely differently
finding your purpose and living it is
the thing that gives you the motivation
the strength the confidence
to show up one more day and keep
living in regret sucks
imagine you are 95 years old you're
looking back on your life at this moment
on this day realizing that you could
have played bigger you could have done
more you had more potential you had an
opportunity in front of you you could
have done something and you didn't you
didn't because you were afraid you came
up with some some reason that you
actually believed that was really an
excuse you played small you didn't
accomplish your goals now you're 95
years old and it's over and you can't do
it you're not physically or mentally
able to actually do it
the more you can actually feel that
that today matters that you want to stop
living your life by other people's
opinions and stop living with the fear
of regret
stop having that thing hang over your
head that you could have done something
and you were too afraid to do it the
more you can actually feel that it can
push you to actually take an action
because otherwise you live the life that
every Everybody lives that most people
live most people regret their life most
people regret not the things that they
did but the things that they didn't do
regret the ideas that you had then you
saw somebody else make a ton of money
off of you regret the conversation that
you wanted to take but you are too
afraid to go introduce yourself like we
live in this
zone of regret already you can feel it
look back to things that happened last
year two years ago or five years ago
like you wish that you showed up a
certain way you wish that you had more
courage more boldness and you didn't do
it you didn't do it and the point isn't
to beat yourself up over that the point
is to use that as courage to go do
something today towards accomplishing
your goals I used to use the fear of
regret a lot when I was when I was
younger especially to get myself to take
action the biggest decision of all the
hardest decision of all was to when I
was 19 not take the 100K a year dream
job that I thought I wanted to go become
an entrepreneur make 300 bucks a month
own 30 of a company that was the hardest
thing ever and the thing that gave me
the courage to do it was the fear of
regret
and Jeff Bezos has a great uh regret
minimization framework he calls it where
basically he tries to project out to
being you know that old old old old old
man and living life with as few regrets
as possible so I asked myself what will
I regret more
well I regret more saying no to my dream
job
and making six figures and travel around
the world or will I regret more saying
no to this business
and just not knowing
and I thought you know what I can always
go get another job
it may not be the same job it may not be
the same company may not be the same
opportunity may not be as much money it
may not be as much travel may not be
this perfect job but I could get another
similar job I felt like I could get
another similar job this business idea
this business opportunity I didn't know
that I would ever have this chance again
and so I said you know what even if the
most likely outcome is failure I didn't
think it was going to blow up I didn't
know that it was going to work out or
not even if the most likely scenario is
failure I still have to do it because I
don't want to live with regret and I
told myself I would rather know and fail
than not know
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there find your passion when I get asked
you've studied all these people what's
the most common thread that's it find
your passion you have to be doing the
work that you love but how do you do it
how do you find it because most of the
time we know what we don't want you know
the life